[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves with george galloway only on
sputnik radio
kabul has fallen just two days after the
pentagon spokesman said there was and i
quote no imminent threat to cabo from
the advancing taliban tonight the
fighters of the taliban are literally
sitting in the presidential chair in the
presidential palace
and revenge killings have begun i told
you so i told you this would happen 10
000 times
i'm going to tell you what needs to
happen next
and we'll be talking to a considerable
expert about what happens next with
prince andrew and his looming court
battle in new york as a result of his
willful
but ill-fated friendship
with the pedophile child sex trafficker
jeffrey epstein we'll be talking to
limbit opic remember him i do and fondly
he's on about climate change we'll be
talking about the plight of julian
assange whose climate has not changed he
remains in the rancid bell marsh jail
for no crime at all and we'll be talking
to the united states about how the
taliban takeover will affect the rest of
the presidency of joseph biden which
might not be all that long so fasten
your seat belts and get ready to dial in
because this really is going to be the
mother of all talk shows rock and roll
radio with pictures
radio sputnik
we speak your language the mother of all
talk shows the only education you can
get for free
[Music]
george galloway
this is radio sputnik
president biden said that there was
reason to believe
that the 300 000 strong afghan national
army
which was he said as well equipped as
any army in the world
could hold out for up to a year against
the advancing taliban forces they didn't
last a week
just two days after the pentagon said
there was no imminent threat this
evening taliban fighters are sitting in
the president's chair in kabul i mean
literally with their weapons sitting in
the president's chair the united states
secretary of state anthony blinken said
there will be no comparison between
kabul in 2021 and saigon in
but in fact comparison there is and it's
not a flattering one the united states
scramble out of kabul beats even the
scramble out of saigon in many important
particulars to which we shall turn over
the course of this show
but i want to leave you
in this monologue with some thoughts of
some importance
first of all compare and contrast uh the
fighting performance of the 300 000
strong so-called afghan so-called
national so-called army
with the syrian arab army which for 10
years
against a far superior far better armed
insurgency backed by the world's most
powerful countries fought on and on and
on
and ultimately prevailed a sunni arab
army
fighting to defend a secular arab state
headed by a heretic shiite according to
the descriptions of the takfiri
terrorists the taliban of their day
that were invading desecrating
massacring torturing and mutilating the
people of syria just think about that
ten long years the syrian arab army
fought
the afghan national army did not fight
for 10 days after the final offensive
was launched
second takeaway is this
compare and contrast
the attitude of russia
to its ally
syria
with the attitude
abandonment by the american patron of
its ally in
afghanistan and don't think that that
comparison will have been missed by any
of these satrapies that currently
shelter under the umbrella of american
imperial power
the russians stood by their ally the
americans abandoned theirs
and the so-called president of
afghanistan
has already flown out of the country to
neighboring kyrgyzstan though that is
unlikely to be the final watering hole
that he chooses for his long exile he's
likely to end up somewhere
near you as are tens scores maybe
hundreds of thousands of refugees that
are already on the march
into pakistan
into iran
to countries which simply cannot hold or
sustain them
these refugees will not stop marching
in iran or in pakistan
they're marching towards you
just one of the reasons why i opposed 20
years ago
in parliament and on the streets of
london and other cities
rarely on the media because even then
our anti-war message was heavily
censored and often lampooned it's one of
the reasons why i said
that invading and occupying afghanistan
was a bad idea of historic proportions
now what do i think of the taliban
let me tell you what i said in
parliament
almost exactly 20 years ago
in an award-winning speech
i described the taliban and the
excrescence of al-qaeda
which they had clasped to their bosom
that these people
were medieval
obscurantist
savages
and nothing that has happened in the
last 20 years
has made me resile from
that description
it's not because
i liked the taliban i loved the taliban
i was opposing the fathers of the
taliban when britain and america were
stuffing weaponry and money and
propaganda support down their throats
these medieval obscurantist
savages were our boys
back in the 1980s
on the eve of the fall of cabo
to the fathers of the taliban
i told mrs thatcher
you have opened the gates to the
barbarians and the long dark night will
now descend upon the people of
afghanistan and so
it proved i mention all this
not to
bask in the
rapid
20-year vindication of everything that i
said but to try and persuade you to
persuade your politicians to listen to
those who know if i
knew
a graduate of the university of the
streets
from a council house in dundee that no
good could come
of our patronage
of these savages how could the
oxford blues of the british foreign
office and of the government front bench
and of the opposition front bench the
house was virtually
unanimous
about that policy but i and others a few
others knew that it would lead to terror
tears
and blood and so
it did
and so when i argue
for a fresh approach
now that the taliban are in control it's
not because i like them i still
love them
but i want to avoid afghanistan becoming
again
a launching pad
for international terrorism pan islamist
terrorism which imperils
us
all
and i have some ideas as to how that can
be done
but permit me
this observation
our countries are led by fools
jacob rees-mogg has recalled parliament
for next week
next week
he must have listened to the pentagon
spokesman who said there was no imminent
threat
what's he going to say and do
in parliament next week
joe biden
what did he think would happen
when he symbolically for that's all
there was left by the end
symbolically withdrew
2500 american soldiers
the taliban were just waiting for the
queue
it's not that that
2500 american soldiers could have
stopped a taliban advance
but they didn't want the complication
of having to fight their way through
every last dead american
to come to power
as soon as joe biden
began that withdrawal
the queue was there for the taliban to
advance and another dark knight will now
descend upon the people of afghanistan
there'll be no more
lipstick
in the restaurants of kabul
in fact there'll be no more women
in the restaurants in kabul there'll be
no more women in public life at all
in kabul kandahar mazari sharif or any
of the towns and cities in afghanistan
women
metaphorically speaking are about to
disappear there'll be no women in
universities matter of fact there hasn't
been many women in universities or in
public life over this last 20 years the
only time women could freely live in
afghanistan was in the short period
in which
a government ruled
that britain and america and other
western countries destroyed that was the
only time you could really safely wear
lipstick if you were a woman open a book
if you were a woman dream of becoming a
doctor or a scientist if you were a
woman that's why i feel so bitter about
our role in the 1980s in afghanistan i
now watch
particularly on american tv but also
here on social media a long parade of
feminists
who had nothing to say about the woman
whose
head was blown off in front of her
children by b-52s by cruise missiles
they're even more savage
than the obscurantists of the
taliban they had nothing to say
about the destruction of that golden era
in afghanistan that was portrayed as the
anti-soviet war but was in fact
a golden age the only golden age that
there has ever been
in afghanistan permit me
this observation
we
if we pursue
the policy we have been pursuing
of ostracism
sanctions
destabilization subversion siege and
even war
against the new afghanistan
it will turn out just like the old
afghanistan
now is the time to pursue a different
course
let everyone
diplomatically recognize the new
government in kabul
let every embassy open and function
in afghanistan
let not the aid stop
but flow this time not military aid
two trillion dollars has been blown
in afghanistan
let's kill the people of afghanistan
with kindness
let's cooperate
with afghanistan's neighbors
instead of trying to use afghanistan
against her neighbors
let's
deal with
and coordinate with
the government of pakistan
of russia of china of iran who all
border afghanistan
so that an international package
can be properly implemented in
afghanistan because
i've got to pull up what happens next
another 911
another kind of taliban
or another war
the afghans have been fighting wars
against foreign occupiers for millennia
as i've often told you
even alexander the great did not
successfully occupy afghanistan
and boris johnson and joe biden sure
ain't alexander the great enough of war
enough
of fostering
al qaeda and isis type terrorism as long
as it's aimed at somebody
else let's try
a new approach
let's recognize the new government of
afghanistan what choice have we got
they already are
the government of afghanistan the
question now is what kind
of taliban ruled afghanistan
is there going to be
forget ideas about
democracy and and liberalism that ain't
going to happen the only legitimate
interest
as a state not as individuals
but as a state
that we have now with afghanistan
is to
preclude it becoming again
a base for international terrorism that
harms other people beyond their borders
that means
keeping isis out keeping al-qaeda out
making the new power in kabul realize
that there is more to gain
from international cooperation than
there is from international or problem
and condemnation that's my thesis
i'll defend it against all comers in the
course of the show this evening
i expect afghanistan to
dominate the show this evening
but it is not the only
show in town
prince andrew
the son of her majesty the queen
within i think now about 17 days
must
enter a defense
to a case brought
by a woman who was illegally trafficked
for sexual purposes
from the united states to the united
kingdom
by
definitely jeffrey epstein and allegedly
also galen maxwell
the attitude of the royal family to date
has been to complain about nothing
and to explain
nothing that might work
in the differential
media
operation in britain it will not work in
the court in new york
and if we are to avoid
the
surely
supreme indignity of the son of the
queen being found guilty by default
of a sex trafficking crime with all the
consequences that will flow from that
the royal family better get their ass in
gear and very very quickly
and there's much else i could talk about
britain's finest film director ken loach
being booted out of keir starmer's
labour party but
why bother
anybody that's still in
kier starmer's labor is a fool or a
knave
one by one by one by one they're all
being politically
eliminated and still you've got people
hanging on in there for what they never
ever explain
i will be talking
later
about
the latest
monstrosity
of the separatist government in scotland
which has introduced
new regulations
which will compel
teachers
in scotland
if confronted with a child as young as
four
years old who tells them
they'd rather be arthur than martha
to allow that child so to identify
and to use the boys toilets
and the boys changing rooms
and the unkindest cut of all
the school
will be obliged to keep this
metamorphosis
secret
from that child's father and mother
i've put up with a lot
but up with that
i will not put
and i am ready to unite with all people
of good will
in scotland across britain because
scotland is still a part of britain
and decided decisively so to be
to kill this monster
this creep
monstrous creep
of gender bending
with scotland's
innocent children
there's a lot coming up
it's the mother of all talk shows
now
here's my first quest well let me do my
poll first
afghanistan what happens next
a
another 9 11
b be
another kind of taliban
see
another war you can vote right now on my
twitter feed and here's the first
question
in georgia's general knowledge on this
day in which year did the first ballot
voting at a general election take place
a
b
c
answer after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
downloads of the podcast huge numbers
are downloading this week's highlights
in the uk and in the us but also in
countries like japan india denmark saudi
arabia you probably get executed for
that korea switzerland the uae and hong
kong in china thank you for all the
great reviews you've been leaving on
apple podcasts and including this one in
british politics mr galloway stands as
the last bastion of sense like a fine
wine he gets better with age i've been a
fan of his since 2002
i would recommend anyone to listen to
him the best podcast around thank you
very much indeed
that was uh touching testimony thank you
so much
if you do listen give a five star review
why don't
you are listening to the mother of all
talk shows podcast with george galloway
they're bringing drugs
[Music]
let's talk about that
discussing all the controversies and
news across the dis united states of
america tune in to faultlines every
weekday from 7 00 to 10 a.m eastern only
on radio sputnik
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have as long as you have
questions we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik
telling the untold
on this day in which year did the first
ballot voting a general election take
place the answer is 1872 although only
those and such as those were issued with
a ballot now thanks for downloading the
moats podcast this week as a result
listenership is up
more of you downloaded the podcast this
week than in the whole month of june
we're now being listened to in 64
countries including lebanon tanzania
bahrain guinea kuwait iran and many more
to download this week's podcast which
will be ready tomorrow search moats the
podcast from wherever you get your
podcast from or from following the link
on the motes tv twitter
account
now
kirby summers was a popular guest last
time
only an audio i'm afraid to say
she is an investigative journalist and
author of note
and she's right on the money when it
comes to the jeffrey epstein elaine
maxwell and we must add the prince
andrew story which is rapidly unfolding
in a new york courtroom coming your way
very soon kirby thank you very much
indeed for
joining us again
uh i'm right amanda
that if prince andrew does not enter a
defense uh in the next uh i think it's
17 18 days from now
judgment may be uh
given against him by default and damages
of millions of pounds awarded to the
complainant
tell us um you're always right george i
want to first thank you for having me on
again welcome
um
yeah i mean it is a black guy for
buckingham palace he has
from the moment that he receives the the
lawsuit and we do not know if he has
accepted it so from the moment that he
physically touches that document
he has 21 days to respond if he does not
respond you are absolutely 100
right as usual
he will lose by default
and millions might be awarded millions
which
he can't afford and we're not ready to
pay as a people
uh the amount was not disclosed um
it's usually never disclosed so for
example when virginia duffrey who was
also suing prince andrews sued galen
maxwell for defamation the amount was
not of the settlement was not
made public so in this case i am
assuming like you just said that it is a
very large number
um but you know we have to really
consider
uh the
their position
um
for five years david boyce who is
virginia's attorney in this matter has
attempted to get a response some kind of
communication line open with prince
andrew and for five years he has
stonewalled them no response no
communication
nothing and so that basically this
lawsuit
it only happened george because there
was a statute of limitations
which pretty much ends this weekend
i believe because
when she was uh sexually
allegedly assaulted in new york city by
prince andrew in new york
new york's
law meant that she was below the age of
18 so she was 17 at the time that gave
her the ability to sue under
the child
victims right act but that expires
right around now so had she not sued and
really i do not believe it was her first
desire to sue or she would have done it
before
uh this was the last minute thing
they were trying to get prince andrew to
just let's talk about this let's you
know let's
privately
hear a few so
uh you know it could go either way he
could decide um to continue to ignore it
then there will be a judgment however
the matter matter will dissolve right
because there's nothing else to litigate
or
and i've heard that you know there are
other women that he
had access to via gulen maxwell and
jeffrey epstein who
went on to stay on their side
became very wealthy either through
marriage or
their own
adventures in business
and there's one that i know of in
particular who i have been told behind
the scenes is ready to testify on behalf
of prince andrew but then again so is
glenn maxwell yeah i'm not sure that
testimony would be the wisest course uh
for prince andrew to follow if he
responds
within that 21 day period
will he have to appear in this new york
courtroom
i'm sure that prince andrew
probably has a lot of leeway it is a
civil law lawsuit a lot of my followers
and probably many people around the
world
upon hearing this have mixed feelings i
think people are mistaking it for
maybe a
criminal matter that has been brought
against him no it is a civil matter and
as a civil matter even though
it is carried out according to the law
of new york they have some leeway
he doesn't necessarily have to come to
new york he can settle this through his
attorneys you know just attorney to
attorney
let's settle this or if he ha if he does
decide
he wants to take the hard road which i
would recommend personally he doesn't
because this only extends
i mean
the foolishness that he has made his
entire family and all of the uk
by extension go through is
ridiculous so in my opinion i think he
would be wise to settle but if he
decides to be stubborn which we have
seen him
be as in the case of the bbc interview
that he should never have given if he
decides to step into the ring and not
settle then he will be forced to walk
into a new york courtroom yes and
just to set out the facts
she alleges and there is a photograph
which we've all seen
published in the newspapers
by his
testimony that has to be a fake
photograph uh because he says he never
met her
uh he never went dancing with her he
never sweated on the dance floor because
he was incapable of sweating at the time
and in any case it was in a pizza
express in dorking at the date and time
uh right he says he's never or he has no
recollection of ever having met her and
he definitely has never had sexual
relations with that woman
so rather yes there's a he said
she said
element to all this but how would he
explain the photograph unless he can
establish the photograph as a fake
that's correct but what he uh failed to
take into consideration is that there
were other
girls and young women
let's say in jeffrey epstein's new york
city mansion so one of them
johanna schuberg
i i think you probably know and have
heard about this she was in epstein's
home
uh they were celebrating some kind of
another party andrew had so many parties
with epstein and galen but in any event
they were celebrating another party they
gave uh prince andrew
a puppet
that was made in his likeness
johanna schuberg
basically ended up sitting on his lap
virginia drew frey was sitting on
another chair
galen is sort of like the you do this
you do this you do this but prince
andrew of his own volition took the
puppet and put it on johanna's breast so
johanna
will in fact be
uh at least one of what appear to be
several women who will be testifying
you know they can't really say they were
in the same room when it when andrew was
allegedly having sex for slash raping
virginia an underage trafficked girl but
they can say they saw them together so
that alibi that he has that he doesn't
know her he could meet her that is going
to be immediately squashed it's very
flimsy uh that one what can you tell us
about the latest
uh on the galen maxwell story
the last time we spoke uh she was
suffering setback after setback in the
new york courts is it still going
against her
yeah so on friday the 13th she had a
very bad friday the 13th um
you know i think that
what a lot of people
that are not watching this as closely as
perhaps you or i
have missed is that from the very first
day that glenn maxwell showed up in
court which was july the 14th of 2020
they have been trying this case before
our eyes so it's been very uh spy-like
very magic-like so it wasn't just that
she stood before the judge on the 14th
of july and requested bail they also
threw in jeffrey epstein's
non-prosecution agreement and basically
told the judge at that time
throw out the case well
motion after motion after motion has
gotten us to friday the 13th
where basically glenn maxwell and i'm
going to read you the four
attempts to get out of jail that she
presented to the court and you tell me
which one if you want me to expand on
all i will but i'll tell you what she
tried
number one she tried the bill cosby
defense
number two she tried the double jeopardy
defense the third defense of course is
the fallback jeffrey epstein
non-prosecution defense and the fourth
one is the man act
she was denied on all four but if you
want me to explain this what's the
what's the man act
the man act is when uh
someone is transported across state
lines for the purpose to be trafficked
now in this case when she tried to have
it applied to her
it does have a five-year statute of
limitations and her argument is well
i'm being tried for the years 2001 and
2000 through 2004 so this applies to me
judge allison nathan who was presiding
over the case said no no no
no no no and and i'll tell you why
and she said not only did you transport
them across state lines but you partook
you sexually assaulted them too denied
wow and what's the bill cosby defense
just for those who are not following
that particular one as closely as us
so bill cosby had a verbal
non-prosecution agreement in the state
of new york uh with a certain prosecutor
when that person
retired and someone else took his
position
uh they decided to prosecute him and put
him in jail
his attorneys fought and said hey wait a
minute we have a non-prosecution
agreement this is not supposed to happen
and the
the other person who then took over the
other person's position agreed and said
okay you're right it should not have
happened you go to you get to leave jail
you have your get out of jail free card
glenn maxwell decided if that's gonna
happen to bill cosby
i can get that too the judge said no and
the reason she said no
is because bill cosby
um
his non-prosecution agreement uh
happened in the state of new york
and he only requested that it be
reinstated and sort of reconfirmed in
the same state
and the judge said you're talking about
jeffrey epstein's non-prosecution which
may not apply to you at all which
happened in
in florida so
no on that one too
so she lost all these uh four counts it
was a very bad uh friday the 13th for
her
what comes up next kirby
well
they're trying to get the um
the trial is scheduled to commence on
november and what's really interesting
is that she has
really tried to
present herself as a victim meaning that
she has
complained about the water about her
hair falling out about losing weight
about unedible food and one would think
that if you are having such a terrible
time in jail
then you want this to be heard sooner
rather than later if you're definitely
as innocent as she is proclaiming to be
so what they really want is for the
case to be not heard in november but to
be heard in the beginning of the next
year and the judge has basically said
okay i'll think about it i'll let you
know so that's outstanding
kirby you are the oracle on this story
we'll be back in touch thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the mother
of all talk shows afghanistan what
happens next a another 911
19 of you think that
a b another kind of taliban
39 of you think that
see
another war
42 percent of you think that let's take
a quick call on it it's a bill in
command bill welcome to the show
good evening how are you by the grace of
god good thank you bill what would you
like to say
well it's actually about prince andrew
yes sir
phoning about i just watched the bbc
uh documentary on the interview last
night
and his defense is
really truer
it does yes it's very weak
it certainly wasn't me i've never been
upstairs in that house before says who i
mean really
it wasn't me because i don't sweat an
adrenaline thing there's no such thing
there's no such condition so if i know
that surely a prosecution is no defense
no defense he's gone for this uh
stonewall this is the old uh
practice of royalty and so on never
complain never explain
he broke that by doing that bbc
interview he did complain
uh he tried to explain the problem was
the explanation didn't cut much ice
oh it was it was uh a few aisle
absolutely pure he would have been
better just
keeping his head down really
so what next i mean where's he
where's he headed next do you think he's
going to answer this charge in the next
17 18 days
well
yes he should
answer it but i don't think he will i
think uh there'll be some
royal charter proclamation uh the queen
will get involved i don't know but he
just well i read today bill that her
majesty is paying his legal bills
uh which means you and i are paying his
legal bills
we'll paying his legal bills okay that's
good he doesn't get legal aid i don't
believe he would get legal aid for one
minute george to be honest with you
there's not much legal aid left uh so uh
if he refuses to answer the charge the
judge will presumably find against him
award damages
to the
woman concerned the young woman victoria
geoffrey as she now is um
and then what he'll just let her whistle
for our money or what
well i think that would be this
if i were he
and thank god i'm not that would be the
sensible course of action
uh and then it's paid not quite out of
court in court but it's still paid and
it's paid to go away
yeah uh i mean that puts him out of
public life in britain forever doesn't
it you couldn't have him on the
buckingham
palace value straight uh when when an
american court has found him to be a
rapist
no it will it will it will be sadly
missed i'm sure uh probably the next
it's a royal knockout but
um
that's just what he has to do
he'll go into some form of exile
yeah we'll be paying for that as well
bill thanks very much for that call uh
on this day in which year did britain
grant independence to india and pakistan
a 1946
b
c
how's that
radio sputnik
[Music]
you know and it's a very thank you for
you know i'm a big fan of your show gigi
great great debate great and i'm
scottish i'm very passionate about
what's happening there you know i had a
great mom she was scottish mary mcleod
she taught me well she taught me well in
everything including golf
i love scotland and i love the scottish
food this great food i said to melania
you know haggis look at that
much more than more scottish than that
me
i am that haggis she said what thin
skinned and full of crap
sputnik has been launched to give you a
closer look at everything happening in
the world
radio sputnik telling the untold
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends contributors and
callers everyone is welcome
ah the answer is 1947 india and pakistan
on this day independent in 1947. now
here are the phone numbers if you're in
the united kingdom
it's absolutely free remember it's
081-965522 that's 08081
965522 and if you're in the united
states it's equally free
and the number is plus one
eight four four nine four four double
three double four that's plus one eight
four four nine four four double three
double four
now my next guest was a
parliamentary colleague of mine for some
years a parliamentarian of some note
actually a man always guaranteed to
raise the awkward difficult question and
not to take necessarily no or yes for an
answer nowadays he's the director of
communications at motorcycle action
group he is of course the former mp
limbit opec limbet welcome
to the show wonderful to see you again
that's not a very environmentally
friendly job is it are motorcycles not
polluters
well actually uh if we shifted from four
wheels to two you would cut emissions
because by definition an a motorcycle
with a tiny fraction the weight and size
of a car so you should start using a
scooter and you can go electric if you
want to as well so uh actually and the
list of
offenders that's one of the very few uh
that i would actually say you're not
doing too badly if you shift from four
wheels to two
good answer i'm sure you've done that
before uh the uh the big conference
coming up this year in glasgow of all
places which is somewhat polluted city
these days uh um rats are running wild
the nationalist
controlled local authority can't even
empty the bins it's going to be a
potential embarrassment for those of us
who love the city but the whole world's
coming there and there's a frenzy
building
uh how do you view it all
hypocrisy that's how i view it we're
told not to travel we're told not to fly
but while everybody else can do virtual
meetings like you and i are doing now
apparently
these people the environmental
lists all over the world they can fly to
get together in glasgow uh and so needs
to explain why this do as i say not as i
do is in any way acceptable in terms of
the debate itself and perhaps this is
where we really get into the controversy
i'm not even convinced that what they're
talking about is on the money
scientifically
well
there's a few people like that i'm one
of them and you're another but tell us
what you mean by that
uh what i mean is that it seems to me
that the virtue signaling which goes
with this this remorseless climate
emergency
terminology uh where we're being told
that we've got 100 days or five years to
save the world i just actually think
it's it's gone crazy now and it's
totally diverted away from science give
you one example you think the polar
bears are going extinct but actually
more polar bears now than have been
since
1960s uh antarctic is melting away
actually it looks like antarctic is
showing no real signs of climate change
at all that's an
arguable point uh but it's certainly not
the case that everything is indicating
uh that we're heading into a terrible
phase of global warming and here's the
fundamental thing george i'm not even
persuaded that the climate that is
changing is being caused by human beings
in any significant way
uh what else could it be just cyclical
it is cyclical there's no one of the
things that really annoys me when i
debate this with with people from the
green movement is they say we're going
to stop climate change
well good luck with that because the
climate has changed for the last two and
a half thousand million years that's
roughly length of time the atmosphere
has got the proportions has got in it
now we've had ice stages we've had warm
periods and so when they say uh oh well
you're a climate change denier no it's
the other way around i'm insistent that
the climate will always change and we're
not going to be able to stop that
what i'm really bothered about though is
that they give the impression that the
human race is so powerful that they can
actually stop these cyclical movements
there's something called the melancholic
cycles uh the greens probably think
that's a kind of a bicycle actually it's
the way the earth goes around the sun
how it wobbles and how it rotates
melancholic cycles seem to be really
important in my view to the way that
they are get treated and cooled when it
gets further away from the sun there's
less heat now nobody in these
demonstrations has even heard of that
until we can have a proper scientific
debate where people can disagree with
what i say but until we have a proper
debate we're not actually going to get
close to the science and instead what
happens is people like me get shouted
down is climate change deniers with all
the sinister undertones that face has
there's a lot of uh
political cross-dressing uh on this
issue
many of the people that are most up in
arms
about being forced to wear a mask and so
on
[Music]
are amongst those
who are effectively calling for a real
proper tyranny uh the tyranny of
the environmental lobby which will
change our lives if they can
in ways which are far more
disruptive
unpleasant and profound
than the mere wearing of a mask in tesco
cox from fairfield uk has just launched
a report which estimates the cost of
going carbon neutral just for the uk is
1.4 trillion pounds that's just a
ludicrous amount of money especially if
you do begin to realize the climate will
always change
secondly as you say there is this
tyranny where i am bound to get
criticism for talking on your show
i'm daring to question the orthodoxy
which is the new religion which is the
environmental emergency
we're all going to die it's our fault
but if you repent you will be saved and
that's the problem we've got so i'm
beginning to speak up saying okay come
and have the debate challenge the
figures i've got tell me about why
the polar bear population has increased
then tell me why you think what you do
about the antarctic if we can actually
begin to have that a serious debate then
we're making progress but you get
shouted down as a climate change denier
as i said before and that isn't science
the scientific method has been thrown
out the wind and replaced by that virtue
signaling i told you about before what's
going on with the conservative party
they didn't get elected as the greens
and for some reason boris johnson is on
this one i like the guy personally but i
just don't understand why he thinks he's
onto a winner but he's telling us how to
live our lives but inviting thousands of
people to fly to glasgow when they could
all do it on zoom like you and me this
evening it's the apocalyptic uh approach
which disturbs me that
we've lived through you and i have lived
through you've got five days left to
save the nhs you've got seven days left
to save the pound uh you you may even be
too late to save the planet but we need
to try anyway i mean this
apocalyptic approach
uh the greta thornberg approach
weeping
bitter tears
blaming
her parents generation her grandparents
generation and so on
just like the covid
thing
it's it's going to prove
very deeply divisive
and
in the same vein
lacking in scientific precision
more more more more heat than light
that's exactly the problem george take
for example co2 not many people realize
that the plenty of evidence is not
conclusive but plenty of evidence
suggests that co2 is a lag factor
what that means is it could be that the
evidence suggests
as temperatures go up then co2 goes up
as temperatures come down then co2 comes
down it's not really clear what the
relationship is there but we're being
told that something which is essentially
a trace gas and a good fertilizer
because we depend on it for a plant life
co2 is wrecking the planet well water
vapor is 490 times more important as a
greenhouse gas uh than than co2 but we
fixate on co2 because they can ban
petrol motorcycles they can ban your car
and your diesel and everything else ban
your your gas stove for that matter
because it's been made the enemy
actually there's an argument to say that
we should have more co2 because it
greens the planet nasa which is some
extent complicit i think in the abuse of
science on this one but nasa itself
admits that the world's got greener and
it's probably because there's a bit more
co2 and what do we do in greenhouses
professional greenhouse
operators they triple the amount of co2
that's in those greenhouses because the
plants love it any gardener knows this
but you can't get to the science exactly
because of that tyranny because you're
shouted down you're excluded or you're
told oh we don't need to have balance on
this because the science has settled as
soon as someone says that they've
abandoned science yes
well the afghan
story that we're covering tonight is
another good example when the house of
commons was unanimous about something it
was almost always unanimously wrong
none of us i presume
are saying that we should not try
and lead a cleaner greener life
that we should have less plastic
less waste keep the plastic out of the
oceans
maintain our wildlife and our
insect diversity and so on we're all in
favor of that
we just don't want to wear a hair shirt
and go and live in a cave as the epitome
or the apex of human civilization do we
exactly i've got solar panels on my roof
it's a decision i fully regret by the
way because it's so uneconomic it's
unbelievable and
i greened my house up in wales not that
anyone cared they still voted me out but
i'm not bitter about that i reduced the
consumption to 300 watts in that house
i did that because it's just smart if
you can get a car which does 80 miles
per gallon instead of 50 what's not to
like but
so sensible husbandry of our resources
is a really good idea and also
i i don't like the idea of pointlessly
wasting uh those resources where i
really object is that panic the climate
emergency but here's the danger a bit
like the wildfires in greece this is
going to burn itself out because when
the world doesn't collapse when we do
get a heavy snow one winter when the
temperatures go down all of this people
will just decide hang on we've been sold
a pup here but at what cost george the
danger is we'll have banned uh petrol
diesel vehicles by 2030 which i don't
think is scientifically sustainable and
even more that we're going to have
outages in the bridge because where's
all the power coming from same people
who want us to drive electric despite
the millions of tons of electric battery
waste that's going to create don't like
nuclear power and you're not going to be
able to do this with solar and wind and
they were against the seven barrage ever
since i was at university in bristol so
they created a
hopeless situation where eventually
something's got to give and i suspect
it'll be the environmental
agenda and watch this now china really
uh coming up with their economic
successes on they're more than happy to
sell us all these electric vehicles and
everything else without doing it
themselves why because they're going to
be far more economically viable than for
example britain so we're going to become
the poor relation precisely because of
what i think is a scientifically
extremely shaky agenda and it's as i
said before about virtue signaling about
looking about who can be the greenest
regardless of whether that's what's best
for them for the world well they're all
vying but as you say the most surprising
one is is the conservative party
it's worth i think uh finishing on this
point
that there's actually nothing all that
conservative
about the british conservative party
right back to david cameron's hugging uh
huskies and all the rest they've been
adapting and adopting every fad
every liberal fad small l limbit every
small liberate liberal fad that comes
along why
uh
i'd i'm gonna invite boris live on your
show here's an exclusive for george
let's just have a chat i'll lay the
science as i see it and and he can ask
any question he wants and if i don't
know something i know quite a lot about
it i study this professionally if i
don't know something i'll tell him but
i'll also tell him where they're wrong
why some people suspect because there
are influential people in his close
family others say that he just wants to
green the blues
or thirdly it might simply be because he
can't resist this bandwagon and he got
cop 26 coming out when he can look by
world leader as i say boris i like you
i want you to do well but you're not
doing well for the millions of people
who voted conservative in this country
it didn't vote green so please give me
the chance to share the science and i'll
show you why i am skeptical about the
fact that there's a climate emergency
there isn't there are cycles in climate
change they've always been there we make
some small difference but at the end of
the day co2 feeds the world it doesn't
destroy it
well we'll pass on that invitation right
after the show limbo opec uh of the
british motorcycle sorry the motorcycle
action action group otherwise known as
mag or maggie uh i never thought i'd
hear that acronym applied to you lemba
opec thank you very much indeed for
joining us on the mother of all talk
shows afghanistan what happens next
another 911 19
another kind of taliban
40 percent another war 41
you can vote for the next hour or so on
my twitter feed coming up
we've got
the julian assange
issue uh his
calvary continues we've got the
wonderful anya parampel on the united
states response to today's events in
afghanistan and we've got a follow-up a
victory for britney spears hip hip
hooray that's all i can say let me do
some social media in the minute i've got
left uh this from chris conway the
media's gnashing of teeth over the
taliban at the door of kabul is
disgusting and hilarious two quick
observations one today's references to
neglect to mention most of the
terrorists were saudis and two what
about the women in syria iran yemen and
saudi arabia
textbook manufacturing consent today and
carlos says the u.s got out of
afghanistan to support an intervention
in iran kevin hughes says i'm sure it
won't be too long until we see the
american saudi-backed militias at the
iranian border and captain thunk says i
doubt the taliban will do anything
provocative enough to invite war or
airstrikes anytime soon and imran
says there's little to worry about
with the land being used for training
camps as they are all over iraq syria
and libya now
and ian kirk says taliban extremist
influence will spill over into pakistan
russia and china team up to exert
influence over the taliban to do their
bidding america will now be viewed as a
failed superpower
much more coming up after the break stay
tuned
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get for free
radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news
afghan president ashraf ghani addressed
the recent advancement made by the
taliban to the capital city of kabul in
a televised broadcast on sunday he made
the statement before fleeing the country
for tajikistan the update followed the
announcement that the group had arrived
at the outskirts of kabul after seizing
large parts of afghanistan within a week
president ghani flew out of the country
two officials told the associated press
news agency speaking on the condition of
anonymity because they were not
authorized to brief journalists local
media reported that ghani left for
tajikistan the taliban which for hours
had been on the outskirts of kabul and
out soon after that they would move
further into the city gripped by panic
throughout the day as helicopters raced
overhead to evacuate personnel from the
u.s embassy smoke rose near the compound
a staff destroyed the important
documents several other western missions
also prepared to pull their people out
civilians fearing that the taliban could
reimpose the kind of brutal rule that
all but eliminated women's rights rushed
to leave the country as well lining up
at cash machines to withdraw their life
savings the desperately poor who had
left their homes in the countryside for
the hope for safety in the capital
remained in their thousands in parks and
open spaces throughout the
city afghanistan's acting defence
minister general bismillah khan
muhammadi said the capital was secured
despite reports of the taliban entering
kabul on sunday kabul is secure your
security and defence forces are
committed
to their promise of defending kabul he
said international forces are ready to
provide whatever help to the afghan
security forces said muhammadi everyone
is ready to defend kabul just some
enemies of kabul are trying to spread
propaganda in order to make people lose
confidence he concluded
earlier on sunday it was reported that
taliban forces were at the outskirts of
kabul after seizing large parts of
afghanistan within a week the recent
taliban offensive follows the u.s and
other nato forces ongoing withdrawal
from the country
scenes now of the aftermath of the
magnitude 7.2 earthquake that struck
haiti which included a hotel level to
the ground and scores of injured as seen
in les cayes on sunday footage shows the
hotel le manuere reduced to rubble and
injured people including children being
treated outside the afatima hospital at
least 724 people were killed and around
3 000 were injured after an earthquake
hit the country's south west on saturday
morning the quake comes over a decade
after a disastrous 7 magnitude shock in
2010 that struck closer to the country's
capital of porter prince killing an
estimated
220 000 people arielle henry the
country's prime minister said on
saturday that local hospitals
particularly in the city of la scales
were overwhelmed with wounded and
fractured people more than 300
firefighters and 21 aircraft fought
against the flames on saturday night and
in the early hours of sunday in an
attempt to control the wildfire and the
zuba the fire apparently caused by a
lightning strike began at 8 30 pm local
time after which air and ground means
were sent to fight the flames the fire
started late in the afternoon almost
sunset so airplanes have barely been
able to discharge water over it
explained to firefighter adding that it
evolved rapidly due to the high
availability of wood and the low
humidity that we have suffered during
these three days the virulence of the
fire forced the residents of castelleon
municipality to be evacuated
preventively in the middle of the night
before being relocated to the
neighboring towns of soneja and sot
deforest eight people were killed and
dozens were injured when a bus rolled
over the side of a road near the village
of shabachian about 70 kilometers west
of budapest on sunday the bus registered
in hungary which was carrying around 50
passengers is believed to have struck
the side of a bridge overlooking the
road two people were reportedly
seriously wounded while 46 others
received light injuries
a man claiming to be a former inmate of
a jail in afghanistan's lakshagar said
he and other prisoners were released
after the taliban took over the city he
was seen greeted by friends and
relatives waving the white flags of the
group and the chamin border crossing
between pakistan and afghanistan
lakshagar is one of the provincial
capitals that were seized in taliban
swift defensive earlier in the week
quote i was imprisoned at lakshagar for
three years and six months there was
cruelty and hardship there was
oppression on the part of afghan
government said alleged former inmate
safula who added i am very happy that
the government of the islamic emirate
has come
the recent taliban offensive has been
triggered by the u.s and other nato
forces ongoing withdrawal from the
country president joe biden announced
earlier in july that all u.s troops were
to withdraw from afghanistan by august
31st just before the 20th anniversary of
9 11.
and finally around a thousand people
cycled naked in the streets of london
for the annual world naked bike ride on
saturday to raise awareness towards
climate change and the overuse of fossil
fuels small groups coming from different
parts of the uk merged in the city
centre and rode their bicycles in an
organized and peaceful protest against
the fossil fuel industry and for the
rights of bike riders quote we're
breathing in the fumes we're getting hit
by cars and everything so we want more
space to move around freely in a healthy
environment said tony a cyclist who
participated in the ride held each year
since 2004 the world naked bike ride is
a clothing optional ride in which
participants usually cycle naked to send
a message in favor of a cleaner world
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves with george callaway
only on sputnik radio
we're being flooded with telephone calls
uh i promise you we'll make as much
space for them as possible this evening
and of course the social media
afghanistan is dominating but prince
andrew climate change julian assange and
many other issues too on which i now
introduce my next guest dr polona
floriancic is here to speak on julian
assange she's one of the founding
members of lawyers for assange who have
now been fighting
for his liberty for more than a decade
it's almost impossible
to believe dr polona thank you very much
indeed for uh joining us let me
summarize we we cover this story a lot
on this show but for those perhaps
listening
for the first time in a while
julian won his case in january the judge
decided not to extradite him
inexplicably
she a allowed the us government to
appeal it but worse
b
uh demanded that he be kept in the
maximum security hellhole designed for
mass murderers and terrorists at
belmarsh prison where he's kept
as peter hitchens the celebrated english
journalist put it today in the daily
mail as if he were a mobster as if he
were a mafia chieftain
all with great toll on his mental health
which of course was sufficiently fragile
for even the somewhat partial
judge uh barrestar to decide not to
extradite him in the first place uh
what's the
legal situation now
um well thank you very much for having
me number one uh i just want to make
clear that lawyers for assange is not
associated with assange's legal team
we are of independent observers just for
the audience not to be confused
what is the situation now as you've
mentioned the professor koppelman the
neurosec
psychiatrist who gave the expert opinion
of on assange's mental health and on his
suicide risk is now being challenged and
this is what happened this week
at the high court or the royal courts of
justice another ground for appeal was
approved and this is that his statement
misled the judge now this is very uh
problematic to claim because before the
first hearing the judge already knew all
the facts and the facts here which are
supposedly problematic is that in his
first report
professor koppelman did not mention that
stella morris and max and gabriel were
the family of julian or that she was his
partner and they were his children
but before judge beretzer even had
heard evidence at the first hearing she
already had this information and in the
second report from the professor he
already spoke about this he did not hide
this fact and the reason he
hid this fact so to speak was because of
the concerns for the well-being of
stella and the children so he was just
protecting their privacy by not
mentioning their relationship with
julian assange now the judge beretser
who as you've mentioned hasn't really
been the most um
what's the word she has shown her
dislike of julian on many occasions and
in her decision apart from you know
saying no to the extradition on on the
ground that he may commit
suicide if extradited apart from that
she has accepted all the arguments from
the united states so in in every other
sense that judgment is highly
problematic or sorry decision
now my point is
professor koppelman was just trying to
protect stella and the kids from what
they are experiencing now which is
death threats and and threats to their
security and i'm sure you've seen stella
speak outside the court and she could
hardly contain her tears which i'm sure
she feels
extreme injustice that this is now being
used to challenge the expert opinion
that has led to the um refusal of the
extradition that her safety and the
safety of her children and also daniel
the the
the other son of julian assange who's
also receiving threats that that
considering the protection of them is
now being used
as to somehow undermine the expert
opinion of professor koppelman
altogether and and where's the
connection nobody knows why the expert
opinion would not be uh would not hold
uh
its value it its merit
because this was not mentioned in it
and
the the united states or the the
prosecution is claiming that this has
misled uh judge beretzer but she herself
said she was not misled she understood
why
uh the the information was not disclosed
at that point and she has since heard
the full story so so her decision was in
no way
influenced by that uh now timothy
holroyd
who's the um
chief justice um at the
royal courts of justice who decided on
this this week he himself said that it's
highly uh unusual for the royal courts
of justice to consider
the evaluation of the evidence by the
district judge but that he is allowing
this uh you know to be argued at the
appeal
the appeal is in uh october uh i think
in summary we can say
that because a new ground for appeal
has been added uh the danger of julian
being extradited to the u.s
just got greater
if it had been the simple appealing
against baristas finding
in october uh julian would have been
safer than he now is is that correct
it's absolutely correct at the beginning
three of the grounds for appeal were
granted now now it's all of them so with
every you know further grounds for
appeal the threat is greater but the
hope is that the other judges
will be more reasonable and and will
still uphold the findings of the expert
witness and still consider the risk of
suicides to be great
and
i know you don't speak for julian's
lawyers that's an important dichotomy to
make
but in your opinion as a lawyer
why
is he still being held
in these
cruel
and unusual circumstances he has not
been convicted of any offence
beyond skipping bill that he's already
served
one year in prison for therefore he's an
untried prisoner
not charged with any criminal offence
here in britain why is the british state
disgracing itself
with this
treatment of a very high profile
political prisoner
it's not just the state which is
disgracing itself it's the justice
system because this is not a normal
proceeding that's that's as
as the jurist i i can say that this is
not normal and this shows that it's
actually a political proceeding and all
i can say about him still being in
belmar it's grotesque
the bail skipping part was actually him
seeking and being granted asylum this is
not the same as
quote-unquote normal bail skipping and
even if it was normal bail skipping in
most cases in the united kingdom they
don't even get
any punishment or if they do it's
something minimal he got the longest
punishment and if even after that was
over he is still in belmar and why
belmar is he a war criminal is he you
know has he committed crimes against
humanity or has he revealed them
so
as a lawyer i can tell you this is
political
well uh the the criminals made it a
crime uh to report uh on their criminal
behavior that's the
long and the
short of it i'm grateful to you for your
uh coming on the show tonight dr polana
florian chich thank you very much indeed
for joining us on the mother of all talk
shows now the poll is uh
uh going uh if you'll forgive the pun
great guns uh what happens next in
afghanistan another 911 19
another kind of taliban 40
another war 41
on the youtube poll
that was the twitter poll on the youtube
poll it's almost identical another 911
another kind of taliban 48
another war 39
so you can let me have your point of
view either
on twitter or by email directly into the
studio
or on the phone here's the numbers 08081
965522 if you're in the uk it's
completely free if you're in the united
states it's equally free but the number
is plus one eight four four
nine four four double three double four
and i mentioned the emails email the
show anytime at on air
at motes dot
tv
uh saber crosby says george ivan sokolos
won't come to england to face trial for
the death of harry dunn
then why should prince andrew
go to the usa over an allegation with no
evidence
and david says kirby is an amazing
researcher anyone who doesn't follow her
go to her twitter
p.s if gulen gets to trial she will sing
like a canary and robbie the pict says
andrew is hiding in the crown estate at
balmoral so he can't be handed the
sabina and john says send prince andrew
to fight the taliban
and
shahid says we should send tony blair to
talk to the taliban and big g haywood
says so-called terrorism is nothing more
than a psyop a cia counter insurgency
program
and glenn says watch the usa ramp up the
uyghur issue now this is to exacerbate
any
potential
problem between
afghanistan and its neighbor china and
tony lawlor says americans think if you
don't turn your country into a shopping
mall with a mcdonald's on every corner
and a starbucks on every other corner
you are not a democracy
and 712 dao says the goal was never to
win the war was very successful the
surveillance state is stronger than ever
constitutional rights are trampled upon
and the defense budget is higher than
ever
well that's true
of course but it's not the whole truth
the united states has now suffered a
cataclysmic blow to its global prestige
every satrapy as i put it earlier
currently depending on the united states
to defend them to keep them in power
now is looking at the pictures from
afghanistan as in another earlier era
they looked at the pictures coming out
of saigon and they see a false friend
they see a tiger which is not a paper
tiger but is an old tiger some of whose
teeth have fallen out its remaining
teeth not as sharp as before and its
heart for the fight much weaker than
before trust me
for those of you and i see some
conspiracy theorists projecting it in
the social media that i'm getting here
who imagined that somehow the americans
planned
on this abject humiliation that joe
biden planned
to be
a figure of ridicule
a reasonable
old senile man
which is what he looks this evening
then that is a conspiracy theory too
far
now let me give you uh the next question
in this week in which year did elvis
presley die
a
1973 b 1975
c
i know the answer to that because
my birthday is elvis's death day
and so for many years my birthday was
more melancholy than it would otherwise
be
as each year passed
because i had to listen to
elvis all day on the radio not in the
context of his greatness but in the
context that my birthday was the day he
shuffled off this mortal coil anyway the
answer to which year elvis died comes up
right after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
let's take a call go ahead kenny hi
george here i just want to talk about
the trans issue that you were speaking
about earlier
in front of me by uh douglas murray and
he's got a paragraph here uh just like
that we do if that's okay oh yeah go
ahead
okay
uh we're
standing on the corner
all right
i'll get him off get him off he's a
nutter
it is a nutter
in the uk it's
0819 six five
five two two and in the us it's plus one
eight four four nine four four double
three double four
[Music]
questions are the most powerful weapon
we have as long as you have questions
we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik
telling the untold
elvis died on my birthday 16th august in
1977.
i remember it well
i was in a place called the handsome cab
in dundee when the news broke the
jukebox was busy with elvis songs that
evening now let's take calls right up
till nine o'clock we've got plenty of
them first up is tarik in london go
ahead tarek
hello um um hello jeff um i've wanted to
make a comment about the fact that
feathers taliban have have changed or
they are the same taliban that they were
in 1996.
i unfortunately was present in 1996
takeover of the capital
and i was witness to the way dr
najibullah was brought out and hanged in
aryana truck
in fact dr najibullah was killed and
brought out dead to be hanged his
brother ahmad shahpur was actually
hanged
in aryana chalk
and i contrast that with today's
takeover of kabul although i get to sit
in the comfort of london now but it is
um a much different uh example of a
takeover compared to 1996.
so far
so far but we saw the capture of
ismail khan an arden
enemy of the taliban he was captured in
herak but then released
and put back on the plane and sent to
kabul to convey taliban's message to the
opposition so um there have been some
very positive developments and we have
to applaud taliban and we have to
encourage them to continue on those
positive developments rather than to
bring out the demons from the past and
and try to push them to to to kind of go
in that direction but what we are seeing
right now is something that is a very
positive sign and a lot of talk has been
made on on human rights and whether for
girls would be allowed to go to school
or not the problem was not the taliban
were not allowing those to go to school
the problem was the way the schools were
presented to the afghan population
schools were being used by the communist
government to
brainwash the kids and they were
literally pressing that uh dressing the
girls up in dresses that they were
talking in contrast with local culture
and that was a real problem if schools
could be presented in a positive way
taliban called absolutely no problem
with allowing girls to go to school and
this is something that they have been
saying and recently we have seen that
the at least the taliban policy is that
we will not uh stop girls from going to
school what happens under individual
commanders in some way isn't all
different thing but not taliban
but don't just gloss over it because
it's an entirely different thing
afghanistan is a big territory uh it is
uh habitually lawless subject to
warlordism
uh the
girls have already been taken out of
their workplace and driven off and told
not to come back in
several of the so-called liberated areas
i find your caricature
of the school and universities
in the pre-taliban
era quite grotesque i must tell you
that girls were being dressed up didn't
girls have the agency of dressing as
they wished
in defiance of local custom as defined
by who by you or other men
dr najib bella was a friend of mine so i
recall recall his fate uh in nightmarish
terms
i have absolutely no reason to resile
from my description
of these people as medieval obscurantist
savages
but i did say
at the top of the show perhaps you
missed it
that the way
forward now that they are back in
control
is to engage with them
not to
sanction them
ostracize them quarantine them besiege
them subvert them we must now accept
that the taliban are back in power and
tried to do our best to
mitigate
that obscurantist savagery and above all
to stop the taliban
going down the road they did go down
of allowing every tom dick and harry of
the al-qaeda persuasion to use their
territory as a base for international
terrorism surely you can go with me on
that
but to be very honest as far as the
al-qaeda and taliban never wanted them
to be there that al-qaeda was left over
to the taliban uh by the by the
hikmatyah and the rest they invited
had the warmest possible relations with
osama bin laden
why are you apologizing uh for the
taliban in this
because i have seen i've seen the
positive things up there that was the
only four years in afghanistan that had
any semblance of peace when he said
afghanistan is a fractured country and
it has never been under single control
during the taliban time it was under the
single control although it was in
extremely brutal control but that was
the only time in that island well i'm
glad you can see they're extremely uh
brutal uh you you don't work for
pakistan intelligence at tariq do you
uh no not really in fact i was
imprisoned by the taliban i was kept in
prison for around 21 days in taliban
because i've been slapped kicked and and
and
literally more or less one could say
tortured during the third month and i've
got no excuses to make i was rather
close to hikmatia
when i was a journalist managed to go
around to afghanistan more often but uh
bringing it down to bin laden's uh thing
uh
umar was fed up of bin laden he hated
the fact that bin laden was running his
own show in afghanistan it was only when
mr clinton uh was involved with monica
lewinsky and in order to divert the
internal politics he launched a cruise
missile attack on afghanistan in house
that's what really infuriated the the
the malamar and he said okay fine now
now he is my honorable guest and i will
defend him
but whatever the case was in those days
taliban had just come out of a village
and had ended up having the whole
country they were not experienced now we
would hope you said the taliban are back
in power out so they're not yet back in
power they haven't formed the government
they are still the insurgents who have
won the war but they haven't formed the
government yet but we would hope that
they will be different and i'm seeing
signs that they do seem like as if they
are much different than what they were
in 1996. okay a pleasure of disagreeing
with you thanks for the call tarik
maureen is in scotland in clark manisha
go ahead maureen
hello george thanks for having me on
excuse my voice
and
i'm going to talk about the
snp
proposal
about children
uh
changing gender at the age of four and i
don't understand
why they need to keep a secret
and
i find
that that just find the whole thing
terrible and worrying
it's hard to
deal with
and
i'm also worried by the way it's calling
schooling
but this government
is just getting ridiculous
well uh it's effectively the state
kidnapping or in this case uh the
would-be state kidnapping of children if
you if my four-year-old
uh told her teacher
she no longer wanted to be martha she
wanted to be arthur
uh
under these new rules
uh i will not even be informed of that
and her
four-year-old claim uh to wish to be
author uh will be implemented she'll be
using boys toilets boys changing rooms
uh boys uh sporting activities and so on
now the point is maureen if they want to
take my same four-year-old to the local
park
they need my consent
so they need my consent to take her to
the park
but they don't need my consent indeed
they will keep secret from me
my daughter embarking upon
a life-changing
and potentially
horrifically damaging
uh course of events
without
my knowing and
officially uh keeping it a secret from
me thanks maureen for that call
dave l says america
never had any idea what it was doing in
afghanistan
than it did in vietnam and bargain ninja
says a defeat for virtue signaling
imperialist hypocrites
is a victory for humanity and alan
harris says so trump had an agreement to
leave afghanistan last may
but biden didn't want to give trump the
credit for ending the conflict and
charlie turbo says america allowing
terrorists to regroup
to continue the war on terror
war mongers love terrorists fear is
profitable
and mudassar says as usual the western
media are whipping things up to make
muslims look bad the reason why the
taliban have taken over so easily is
because the people support it the us and
uk tried to impose their immoral godless
promiscuous ways on our women and
society afghanistan will be fine says
mudasa
yes funny how so many men like to
prescribe how women must live
of course the western media that are
whipping up hatred against the taliban
are the same western media that raise
not a jot of concern about the
anti-women politics of places like saudi
arabia indeed we're always running after
saudi arabia to sell them more guns and
to kiss their backside
more succulently
uh hypocrites of course they are andrew
is in london
but it's not prince andrew though he
wants to talk about
uh andrew
yes hello george thank you very much for
taking my call my question is this
what what if andrew doesn't defend the
case and doesn't put any any documents
in and just doesn't say anything you
know the royal precedent anyway is not
to complain and not to comment and
anything like that
and they find him guilty in the jury i
believe it's a jury that award the costs
and award
whatever this woman should get and what
if they say 20 million or 40 million or
whatever how are they going to get it
you know bailiffs don't have any
jurisdiction american bailiffs here
they can't bash down doors he can just
say up your bum and she doesn't get it
excuse the pun
um well
i'll tell you what would happen
uh yeah the
prince andrew the queen's son
would have been found guilty in a new
york courtroom of raping a child
they may not be able to
enforce
the
financial damages awarded though it
would mean that prince andrew would
never again be able to answer enter
the united states
that would be
a matter of some
grave
shame
on our country and it's head of state
would it not andrew uh yes it would be
but um by paying the money
um or setting out of court
um it's the same consequences
you know he's destroyed his life he's
destroyed any future and
the queen
and i believe fergie
i believe it's moved in with him
like a bad penny
yes um
he's outside
her money of course
sorry
jeffrey epstein lent fergie money oh yes
i think he got money off everybody years
and years ago she got money off an owner
of the restauranteur for
10 million pounds loan for a holiday
which she never paid back
so what's your take uh why why why
doesn't he defend the case why doesn't
he
send an attorney
i've never met this woman this picture
is a fake
um it could well be it could well be um
but the jury will not be in his
favor
i believe
that's an odd reason for not defending a
case where the allegations are so
serious
yes but
she was 17
under the law of this country
yeah um where he took her off
allegedly took her off from the
nightclub from tramps
and back to her friends around the
corner
where they had sex but she was 17 in
this country that's not illegal but it
is illegal in new york uh where it is
alleged he also did this
rather unsavory deed as a grown man
he was sleeping with someone as young as
his own daughters
and the the
the allegation is that he had sex with
her in many places including in new york
where it is illegal to have sex with a
17 year old it's doubly illegal if that
child was transported across state lines
too yeah
of uh of illicit sexual behavior and of
course it's even illegal in britain
if
he knew
that she was a minor in the united
states and had been illegally uh
transferred
right right he's not charged in britain
he's charged in america
yes but
um it as he's ruined his life and and
put a huge
blot upon
the royal family
why i pay you the money why pay it it
makes no difference remarkably in susie
you're not the real uh andrew i hope uh
thanks though for the call uh richard is
in manchester let's hear from him go
ahead richard
hello george thank you very much indeed
a great show and thanks for everything
that you're saying about afghanistan you
you yourself were fired by by the
labor government under blair for
opposing the afghanistan war and then of
course the decision as i understood it
to join america uh on
on lies that
iraq had weapons of mass destruction um
okay they then come to the conclusion uh
after the iraq war um as you put into uh
the film uh the killing
of kelly that was the sort of final
action that speeded us to go to
afghanistan and as i understand it in a
book by uh robert croft um blair was
asked um oh uh we we can now it's all
over the iraq war and he said no we're
now going into afghanistan without as i
understand it again any reference to
anybody any government or anything do
you know anything about that george
please well uh they were determined upon
war immediately that 9 11 occurred but
not war against the
country from which the
mass murderers on 911 had come namely
saudi arabia on the contrary as michael
moore's great film fahrenheit 911 uh
showed
on the contrary the members of the saudi
royal family were literally rounded up
by u.s officials when no one else was
allowed to fly
and fly out of the united states
including members of osama bin laden's
family
they were determined upon regime change
across a whole range of states and
afghanistan was merely the first and i
knew
that after afghanistan would come iraq
these criminals
are not only responsible for what
happened today in cabo they're
responsible for
the loss of every life and limb
that took place in iraq and afghanistan
over the last 20 years
in the case of afghanistan
the last
18 years in the case of iraq i saw a
tweet from a man that lost both of his
legs
uh a british soldier who had been sent
on a pack of lies to afghanistan where
he lost his friends and he lost his legs
and he's asking
this evening on twitter
was it all for nothing and he's reached
the melancholy conclusion that yes
indeed
it was thanks for mentioning my film
richard
the dvd
supply has been resupplied and right at
this moment
my good wife gayatri is stuffing
envelopes in scotland so your dvd
if you've ordered one
is in the post or about to be thank you
very much indeed uh for your patience
now
which well-known film was released
this week no no it's bill clinton in it
on this day in which year did bill
clinton admit his affair with monica
lewinsky
a
b
c
answers after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
peter says the afghan people have lost
george i thought you were better than
this to be honest give me a call peter
tell me what you mean
and oliver says for some reason george
was on the jihadist side when it came to
yugoslavia
and that's the reason
i will never trust him
i fought against the war on yugoslavia
with all my breath and all my heart me
and tony ben
and jeremy corbyn
and others
were practically the only people in this
country
opposing the war
on yugoslavia the destruction of
yugoslavia
how dare you you imbecile if you have
any guts you'll pick up the phone right
now
and call this show and justify that
utter
slander
really
and uh yoda says love the show best
entertainment and education on the
airwaves
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have as long as you have
questions we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik
telling the untold
bill clinton finally confessed on this
day in
1998 he did after all have sex with that
woman
uh now this is i think the email of the
night it's from someone who calls
himself malachite
dear george you will probably disagree
with me on this because you are awoken
lefty
long time since i've been called that
i genuinely believe that we need to send
more troops to afghanistan to end our
humiliation and defeat there and install
a leader with guile integrity tenacity
and resolve who will kill the terrorists
i think we need to install
tony blair as the leader of afghanistan
so that britain and the u.s can get its
way no matter what
how wonderful is that kieran is in
sunderland
uh
on the
gender issue kieran go ahead
hello there george how are you i'm good
thanks for calling what would you like
to say
would you agree that is the
16 24 age group that perpetuates this
id poll kind of thing
16 to what
16 24 because yeah yeah i think it's
driven it's driven by very young people
yeah
yeah because because i have lived
loved and laughed with
people
who are transgender gear pansexual
asexual i have lived with these people
and
what is pansexual kieran you'll do it
with anything with a pulse
okay um
let's not get um let's not get offensive
um
pansexual basically means
you you don't care if you love somebody
that's gay that's true that's trans
that's transgender well you've got but
you've got to love them
um we're not going to get to the the 52
different genders kind of thing like
that doesn't exist it that only exists
in the the 16 24
age range when when people are finding
their their political
um
their political life their sexual life
their their personal life for the
getting jobs
and that and it's those kind it's that
age range that's um
that is on social media
yeah and then when you when you get to a
certain age
and you and
nobody
you you go off social social media you
understand what your identity is but
it's only it's only the youngsters that
seem to think yeah oh um yeah but um
look i'm sympathetic kieran to that uh
point of view
and i'm fully seized of the fact that
there is there is sexual fluidity uh
openly uh expressed now in a way
in a way that there wasn't when i was
young and i have no animus towards even
people that
like sex with pans i i just won't allow
my four-year-old or my
seven-year-old or my ten-year-old
to be filled with this at school that is
a straw man you sure you show me a
single teacher that can teach a
four-year-old child about sex
if you can show me that i will bring the
police before you well
you may not be aware of it
you may not be aware kieran let me speak
you may not be aware
uh
of the story that broke this week kieran
please be quiet for a minute of the
story that broke this week in scotland
of new guidelines
issued by
the scottish government
applying to children from the age of
four
upwards
who may now
if they tell their teacher
they are uncomfortable with the agenda
in which they are currently living
be allowed to begin the pathways to
changing it including changing their
name
their personal pronouns the toilet they
use the dressing room they use etc
this is official in scotland
where i live
right now
it is the guidelines to teachers in
every scottish school over to you kieran
can i ask you one thing george yeah
at what age would you allow your child
to express themselves freely
16.
so so you would impose upon
a child with uh with their own um
with their own consciousness you would
you would import like um like almost
like religiously you you would call it
almost like religiously i am religious
but that's not the reason why i would so
impose it
i'd impose it i'd impose it
for this reason
my child is too young to decide to smoke
too young to decide to drink
too young to drive a car
too young to vote too young to do any
number of things and therefore
ipso facto is too young to decide that
though born and brought up as a girl
they now wish to be a boy
crucify me go on
false equivalency my friends false
equivalency why
i think smoking is a lot less damaging
than deciding to change your
uh sex your gender uh nobody as a child
nobody
nobody's asking your child to express to
smoke a cigarette
how weird man stop talking shy all your
life
kieran
apart from your apart from swearing on
the air
uh is this big round sunderland way are
you a spokesman
for the mackham's on this do you think
kieran the gutless coward has run away
let's go to south carolina and talk with
mike go ahead mike
hey george good to talk to you again
first of all first of all i want to wish
you a uh an early happy birthday how
kind of you thanks so much yeah and your
birthday is just two days before mine oh
wow i wish you an ellie happy birthday
too yeah and i am two years your senior
so there
now we got that out of the way okay i
wanted to talk to you about the uh the
the this is twice in three weeks that
you've had two conservative uh climate
desires
he's a liberal democrat
he's a leftist he's a leftist as far as
as far as as far as climate change goes
he's a climate denier just like matthew
was two weeks ago and i'm beginning to
think that you may be leaning towards
some climate deniability on your own
well i'm leaning towards micah's free
speech which is why you're on now you're
on now to give an alternative point of
view and that's what we're going to do
and and i would i would invite you
to have someone else on besides climate
deniers to tell you what's happening
with climate change because it's obvious
many times man many times you only hear
what you want to hear we have many times
i'll listen to you i listen to you every
youtuber
you're all on youtube mike you can go
back we've even had uh um what's what do
you call them climate uh
the climate uh people the main the the
extinction rebellion we even had
extinction rebellion on the show
well
and i'm not saying you know that you
haven't okay all i'm saying is
allowing these people to come on and
talk about this
and and sway these other people that are
that are you know
here's the bottom line yeah
why don't you deconstruct what he said
rather than calling for censorship it
doesn't i'm not it doesn't become not
calling for censorship but but you're
you're uh yes today okay yeah he was
talking about uh how the science is not
proven but the science is all totally
proven it's i mean it's out there for
anybody that wants to look at it it's
right there you look at the ipcc their
newest report
we're in dire dire situation i mean
we need to do something about it we need
to do it now and if there's no political
will to do it we are dooming humanity to
extinction if you look at the facts we
are already in the sixth mass extinction
of this planet and it's all being
brought on by uh uh human activity and
don't you think that's a trifle
apocalyptic mike no we're we're losing
we're losing hundreds of species every
day
just look it up look up the sixth mass
extinction go to
nature bats last look at these things
and find out where we really are because
this guy was talking about how pollution
from cars and stuff wasn't bad listen
just not just carbon dioxide but carbon
monoxide kills so many people in this
world every year i mean i mean it's
happening all of these cases you
remember back when they took lead out of
gasoline you remember that yeah
do you know how many kids and stuff we
damaged irreparably from lead poisoning
okay i'm against petrol i'm i'm quite
okay i'm quite content with the electric
cars
i've driven them let me tell you
something
let me tell you something mike not only
is lambert opec
not
a conservative he would be thought
in britain to be something of a loony
lefty he's a liberal
mp or was
neoliberal no he's proper he's proper
hanging out there liberal he's the most
liberal guy you could possibly imagine
if this was
i'd tell you all the ways in which he is
as liberal uh as can be
what would i
tell you something else mike
until he started speaking i did not have
the faintest idea that he would take the
line that he did i assumed because he is
something of a loony lefty he'd be
taking exactly the same view as you i
mentioned this because i hate it when
people
impute false motive to me or the show i
had no idea he took the line on climate
change that he does i imagined it would
be the absolute opposite let's go
let's go to anthony in detroit because
i'm offended with mike's allegations
anthony in detroit welcome
hey what's going on george thanks for
taking the call welcome so
yeah um you know i hate to say you know
the guy who blew uh got his legs blown
off it it was worse than for nothing it
was a it was a hoax it was a sham as we
i i know you're no uh
stranger to this topic you know a 911
the total sham
so you know we gotta that we gotta start
there we can't have this conversation
about taliban or none of that without
the hoax of 911 it has to be front and
center you know coming up 20 years
in what way was that hoax a lot of
people lost their lives
no doubt no doubt it was a sickening
event but it was a hoax in that they
made other it made it look like taliban
and other people did it but you saw that
you know no i think that's an important
point you're making anthony the last
people in the world that did it were the
taliban uh the taliban are a nativist uh
organization they wanted to and now
presumably will again want to
run their own country they were not
remotely concerned
with the this the length of girls skirts
in copenhagen uh it was
bin laden a saudi and 11 out of 19
saudis
that carried out the mass murder on 9
11.
now but my problem is i don't even
honestly i have a problem with the plane
story too i honestly honestly
i saw it didn't you
i saw them hitting the twin towers
didn't you i believe i believe there
were planes but i believe maybe they
were remotely uh you know remotely flown
or something of that nature yeah um i
really do yeah
i just think that's all barking mad
anthony but thanks anyway phil is in
bristol let's hear from phil
yes hello and thanks so much for
bringing up the south socialist
revolution in afghanistan in 1978
that brought in women's rights and women
could wear what they wanted there's all
kinds of photographs online of showing
women wearing you know
normal clothes
and we've forgotten that and the cia
came in and when you say normal clothes
phil you mean
western clothes
i i apologize yes of course
yeah okay so the point i want to make is
this
mythology that that
suddenly out of the blue the taliban has
swept over the country and wow we're so
surprised the media has taken this up
and the fact is that if if
if the taliban had not been powerful and
had not taken over territory they would
have never negotiated with the taliban
in the first place
and so it shows that the strength of the
taliban was way was like years ago where
they were having negotiations having to
sit down with the taliban where was the
afghan army when when the taliban took
over territory years ago and kept on
taking over more and more territory
incrementally over the years until we're
at the place now and they're acting more
surprised in the media i don't
understand
well i think that's a brilliant call and
i'm grateful
for it uh we were lied to
uh about any number of things we were
lied to
that all the blood that we spent
all the treasure we expended
uh was being used
to build a modern afghan state with a
modern and powerful army
we were not
uh we were bloating the profits
of the military-industrial complex and
literally filling the cash bags of the
corrupt
tyrants that we installed in power in
afghanistan
we were told
that there was an afghan government but
as i've said
for 20 years now
the afghan government's writ does not
run
outside of the congestion charge area of
the green zone in kabul
and the minute that foreign soldiers
leave
will be the minute
that the
uh resistance to them in this case
largely though not exclusively calling
themselves the taliban which means the
students calib means student in in
arabic
they will take power as soon as the
western forces leave we were lied to
systematically by our media by our
politicians the a the invasion of
afghanistan was the right thing to do
the occupation of it for 20 years was
moreover the right thing to do
and lastly that when we ended it
there would be an afghan state left
extant
as soon as we departed all of these were
bright
shining
lies phil thanks for a wonderful call
let's get the nine o'clock news with
jamie lowe
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get for free
radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news
afghan president ashraf ghani addressed
the recent advancement made by the
taliban to the capital city of kabul in
a televised broadcast on sunday he made
the statement before fleeing the country
for tajikistan the update followed the
announcement that the group had arrived
at the outskirts of kabul after seizing
large parts of afghanistan within a week
president ghani flew out of the country
two officials told the associated press
news agency speaking on the condition of
anonymity because they were not
authorized to brief journalists local
media reported that ghani left for
tajikistan the taliban which for hours
had been on the outskirts of kabul and
out soon after that they would move
further into the city gripped by panic
throughout the day as helicopters raced
overhead to evacuate personnel from the
u.s embassy smoke rose near the compound
as staff destroyed the important
documents several other western missions
also prepared to pull their people out
civilians fearing that the taliban could
reimpose the kind of brutal rule that
all but eliminated women's rights rushed
to leave the country as well lining up
at cash machines to withdraw their life
savings the desperately poor who had
left their homes in the countryside for
the hope for safety in the capital
remained in their thousands in parks and
open spaces throughout the city
afghanistan's acting defense minister
general bismillah khan muhammadi said
the capital was secured despite reports
of the taliban entering kabul on sunday
kabul is secure your security and
defense forces are committed to their
promise of defending kabul he said
international forces are ready to
provide whatever help to the afghan
security forces said muhammadi everyone
is ready to defend kabul just some
enemies of kabul are trying to spread
propaganda in order to make people lose
confidence he concluded
earlier on sunday it was reported that
taliban forces were at the outskirts of
kabul after seizing large parts of
afghanistan within a week the recent
taliban offensive follows the u.s and
other nato forces ongoing withdrawal
from the country
scenes now of the aftermath of the
magnitude 7.2 earthquake that struck
haiti which included a hotel level to
the ground and scores of injured as seen
in les cayes on sunday footage shows the
hotel le manugue reduced to rubble and
injured people including children being
treated outside the fatima hospital at
least 724 people were killed and around
3 000 were injured after an earthquake
hit the country's south west on saturday
morning the quake comes over a decade
after a disastrous seven magnitude shock
in 2010 that struck closer to the
country's capital of port-au-prince
killing an estimated
220 thousand people
arielle henry the country's prime
minister said on saturday that local
hospitals particularly in the city of
las cayes were overwhelmed with wounded
and fractured people more than 300 fire
fighters and 21 aircraft fought against
the flames on saturday night and in the
early hours of sunday in an attempt to
control the wildfire and azuba the fire
apparently caused by a lightning strike
began at 8 30 p.m local time after which
air and ground means were sent to fight
the flames the fire started late in the
afternoon almost sunset so airplanes
have barely been able to discharge water
over it explained to firefighter adding
that it evolved rapidly due to the high
availability of wood and the low
humidity that we have suffered during
these three days
the virulence of the fire forced the
residents of castellon municipality to
be evacuated preventively in the middle
of the night before being relocated to
the neighboring towns of sonneha and sot
deforest eight people were killed and
dozens were injured when a bus rolled
over the side of a road near the village
of shabachan about 70 kilometers west of
budapest on sunday the bus registered in
hungary which was carrying around 50
passengers is believed to have struck
the side of a bridge overlooking the
road two people were reportedly
seriously wounded while 46 others
received light injuries
a man claiming to be a former inmate of
a jail in afghanistan's lakshagar said
he and other prisoners were released
after the taliban took over the city he
was seen greeted by friends and
relatives waving the white flags of the
group and the champion border crossing
between pakistan and afghanistan
lakshagar is one of the provincial
capitals that were seized in taliban
swift defensive earlier in the week
i was imprisoned at lakshagar for three
years and six months there was cruelty
and hardship there was oppression on the
part of afghan government said alleged
former inmate safula who added i am very
happy that the government of the islamic
emirate has come the recent taliban
offensive has been triggered by the u.s
and other nato forces ongoing withdrawal
from the country president joe biden
announced earlier in july that all u.s
troops were to withdraw from afghanistan
by august 31st just before the 20th
anniversary of 9 11.
and finally around a thousand people
cycled naked in the streets of london
for the annual world naked bike ride on
saturday to raise awareness towards
climate change and the overuse of fossil
fuels small groups coming from different
parts of the uk merged in the city
centre and rode their bicycles in an
organized and peaceful protest against
the fossil fuel industry and for the
rights of bike riders quote we're
breathing in the fumes we're getting hit
by cars and everything so we want more
space to move around freely in a healthy
environment said tony a cyclist who
participated in the ride held each year
since 2004 the world naked bike ride is
a clothing optional ride in which
participants usually cycle naked to send
a message in favor of a cleaner world
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves with george callaway
only on sputnik radio
it looks to me from here that the
presidency of joe biden is a smoking
ruin
like we must hope kabul will not quickly
become
uh the handling of the decision to
withdraw the final american forces that
were already down to a minuscule 2500
the handling of it the public relations
handling of it have been well as i said
ruinous just two days ago the pentagon
spokesman said there was no
imminent danger of the taliban taking
over kabul two days ago
president biden himself said there was
no reason at all to worry about the
taliban taking kabul and that they had
at least 90 days perhaps as much as a
year
in which they can hold out
there an army he said of 300 000 the
afghan national army and they're as well
equipped as any army in the world
in fact
they were not prepared to fight to
defend the rotten corrupt kleptocratic
puppet regime that the united states had
installed in kabul
they
the afghan national army
decided
that their bones were worth more
of than dying to defend such riches who
have
crept away like thieves in the night
counting their ill-gotten gains that's
how it looks to me here in london let's
see how it looks in the united states of
america where one of my most favorite
journalists in all the world anya
parampill former colleague of mine
indeed on rt america joins me anya how
wonderful to see you again thank you for
being with us uh have i summarized
the situation of the u.s administration
accurately or or do you think i've got
any of that wrong
i think you have described accurately
the way that this looks to many people
who see the united states leaving
hastily from afghanistan and within
hours the capital falling to the taliban
however
i think it's important to note that
many observers would probably agree that
this would be the scenario which played
out in afghanistan whether or not the
united states had left five years ago
five days ago
five months ago 10 years ago 15 years
ago pick a date during the occupation
and this likely would have been the
scenario that's why i'm thinking about
how now in 2012 whistleblower danny
davis a colonel in the us military came
forward and said the u.s public was
being lied to
that
that congress was actually being lied to
that uh
military
elites were
lying to elected officials here in
washington d.c about the
war about the prospects the united
states could win a war that was
ill-defined and i just wanted to read a
quote that he actually
gave the guardian
in 2012 because i think it just really
highlights what we've got now he says
people are not being told the truth
and
what they are actually being told is
that
soldiers were being met with and killed
in a war that was able certain to be a
bloody disaster it's like quote i see in
slow motion men dying for nothing and i
can't stop it it's consuming me from the
outside it's eating me alive and that
afghan soldiers were going to be
incapable of holding on to u.s gains
this is 2012 george
almost 10 years ago we knew this was the
reality and so
i think the reason why now the
situation has come to pass is that
throughout the trump administration this
was a number one campaign promise of
president donald trump and he actually
sent on voice to negotiate directly with
the taliban in order to avoid the kind
of situation we're having now where it's
a violent takeover instead of a
negotiated political solution and we've
actually published at the gray zone an
account
written by gareth porter but provided by
a top trump official colonel douglas
mcgregor who describes how again the top
brass the military command in
afghanistan
when it came to afghanistan undermined
these political discussions
and that's where i think that's what's
missing from the u.s exit we we should
have gotten out a long time ago i don't
think the problem is that joe biden is
leaving i think the problem is that the
united states refused to
talk about any or engage in any sort of
political dialogue with the taliban and
reach a political or diplomatic solution
and
now in u.s media
which i can talk more about later we're
being
inundated with the kind of manipulation
we had for example msnbc host andrea
mitchell
crying on air when she was speaking with
a spokesperson for the state department
ned price saying that what about the
women i've been to this country and
women are going to be
we're turning our backs on those women
she was tearing up and and and these are
all
unfortunately ways that the u.s public
is manipulated into
accepting for example the 5 thousand
more troops that the
administration is going to send back to
afghanistan are sent to afghanistan next
week
and
you would have to be
completely illiterate on the situation
to believe that the united states
actually cares about women in
afghanistan that is
biden himself said that was not the
reason the us was not in afghanistan to
save women he said that during his
campaign
did this msnbc journalist shed any tears
for the women in syria for example where
exactly the same kind of obscurantist
savages
have been cutting off their heads with
american and other western support
no of course not it's it's an imperial
way of viewing the middle east and i
wanted to turn attention also since you
were curious about how the us presses is
covering this i have the new york times
here as well as the washington post and
on the cover of the washington post
today there is a story
that reads
that
the u.s
warrior class is experiencing uh
from went from hubris to humiliation in
afghanistan
and
it actually there's a quote in the
article that i wanted to point out
because they say
that
the afghan reality wrecks us architects
visions of democracy as though of course
that is what we were after in
afghanistan all along and there's a
quote by a civilian who served in the
pentagon during the obama administration
and he says we know what happens when we
fall to imperial hubris
what does one do with imperial
heartbreak
and i just thought that quote was so
profound because
you have the post framing this as an
issue of empire of the us over extending
itself in afghanistan the way
any empire of the past may have told you
could have been the outcome you're not
going to win you're only going to lose
lives and money but this entire article
interestingly enough george is
based mostly on quotes from a woman
named michelle flournoy who biden
actually considered to be his secretary
of defense she's the defense advisor who
served in the obama administration as
deputy defense secretary and she
in the article says that
all along since 2009 the us has known
about the corruption within the afghan
government that it was really a losing
war
and
yet this same woman is the one who was
the architect of the afghan surge in
2009. so i don't understand how
officials such as florinoy
are not going to be held accountable or
how they cannot be held accountable it
just seems outrageous to me how many
lives how much blood is on their hands
how many lives lost because people such
as michelle florinoy pushed ahead with
this war lied to the u.s public as we
know again thanks to whistleblowers such
as colonel danny davis and they're only
going to do it again i fear george
because
whether it's afghanistan
or a new battleground these are always
the kinds of manipulations whether it's
women's rights
or
fighting for democracy that we hear
unless these people are held accountable
i mean they deserve to be put on trial
for the crime of the afghan war
has anyone in the media
asked the question where did all the
money go
if you spent
between 1 trillion and two trillion
dollars
in and on afghanistan
why did it collapse like a house of
cards
what we hear is the c word corruption
corruption corruption i don't think
we're ever really and of course
corruption of afghans we don't really
ever turn and look at ourselves and
wonder how it's possible why was our
military were training an army that they
known for years was it going to be
incapable of holding on to to the
military gains that it made and really i
don't see much critical analysis coming
from the media tucker carlson at fox
news did ask the same question i'm
asking which is why aren't the people
responsible for these policies being
held accountable i think he's an outlier
when it comes to u.s media coverage and
critique of u.s foreign policy
but
we are so
it's so hopeless here we have figures
such as andrea mitchell then you have
megan mccain the son of late senator
john mccain saying that her father would
be
so outraged if he thought was going on
now she said he would be
he would be ragging in public and to
president biden about this withdrawal
from afghanistan i mean that's of course
because her
father
senator mccain
was one of the most
in all of us history pro-war senators
someone who traveled to syria someone
who worked to wage the war against libya
and so these are the kind of figures we
have she's a popular on a popular talk
show that's not political megan mccain
she works or worked for the view
and so if those are the kind of people
who permeate throughout u.s culture
and and media i just don't think we're
going to get critical analysis uh of
course a lot of profits were made by the
military-industrial uh complex a lot of
the top brass in the military that were
sabotaging trump's
attempt to bring the war to an end that
you talked about earlier
all that equipment all those weapons are
now in the hands of the taliban what
could possibly go wrong
again it's not surprising when you just
consider that from the very beginning
all along the united states directly
created the conditions through which the
taliban came to be
through its support for the mujahideen
during the wars in the 70s and the 80s
against the soviet union actually as
my husband max blumenthal wrote about in
his book the management of savagery the
us actually went to kabul and recruited
the most extreme islamist elements in
the
afghan
opposition in order to fund them and
have them lead the war against the
soviet union and of course at that time
he pointed out that women living under
the soviet allied government were saying
what's going to happen to us if these
people are going to take over the
country and we know we've seen how ugly
that reality is so
really no commentator base in the united
states has the right to claim they care
about women or that they're surprised
that these guns are ending up in the
taliban's hands
we
helped create the taliban through the
through the war against the soviet union
and through the instability way in the
1990s the support for various warlords
which ultimately let bin laden come into
the country
and
george
one point that i want to make is that
i was very young when when these wars
started but i remember and still growing
up uh in an anti-war family in an
anti-war community
there
is no question for most people that the
war
that are already
anti-war critical of us foreign policy
that the war in iraq was unjust
and was a crime and had nothing to do
with 911 but there was a sense among
some people not all but
some of the more mainstream anti-war or
critical elements saying that
afghanistan was actually justified
because we weren't attacked on 911 and
and
bin laden was there and so we had the
right to go in and
retaliate against this attack on our
country and it's just ironic again when
we think about the fact that bin laden
escaped afghanistan in tunnels actually
built by the united states during the
dirty war on
the soviet-back government he escaped by
our tunnels and went to pakistan was
staying
in
according to the official story that
they even told us based on his
assassination in a badabad a
place where
he was it was right near a pakistani
military base one of the country's most
closely allied with the united states so
very strange that he would get out that
way
and
again just shows you how the united
states has been constantly chasing its
own tail in afghanistan it creates the
fire and it comes and tries to put it
out but it only ends up spreading
anya
thank you for that wonderful description
of how it's all going down in the united
states much obliged uh to you uh gerard
says your argument appears to be we saw
911 on tv do you believe everything you
see on tv i definitely believe that
those airplanes hit the twin towers and
this from thomas in western bartonshire
it's obvious that you have not found
information that there is an ingredient
in the vaccines that cannot be revealed
as contract between the governments and
vaccine producers prevent anyone from
knowing what it is as it's a trade
secret so you have been objected with
something but you do not know what it is
so have millions of others this is more
serious than afghanistan and requires
public debate
i'm sure you will seek confirmation of
this as the consequences of it could be
serious
well
i got to thinking thomas
that the government of cuba
china
vietnam
russia
even north korea
would be unlikely to be in your
capitalist conspiracy let's hear from
hassan in florida go ahead hassan
hello george how you doing i'm good
thanks for ringing what would you like
to say
oh yeah i wanted to just kind of go over
about this gender thing you have in
scotland at four years old yeah
uh what's what's that about is that
they're uh they're smart enough to now
make a
a wise yeah yeah they can't decide
whether to play with the dinosaur or the
train set but they're old enough to
decide they want to be called arthur
rather than martha
i know when i was four years old uh
i never wanted to put on a pink dress
and uh
also
you know my uh teacher i was you know i
was a pre-kindergarten and she asked me
uh one time what all of us what animal
would you like to be
and i think i said turtle and then she
said why
thing i said to uh to hide from people
ask questions like you that was very
very good for a young
boy at kindergarten hassan well done
thanks for the call let's go to carumbo
in new york go ahead carombo
yeah good good of channel how are you mr
george good thank you thanks for ringing
press on because we're very busy
yeah yeah i know i know i've been
following things for an hour for hours
now actually but yeah i just want to
make a quick comment you know what
happened in afghanistan so my own view
is i will blame the government because
the afghan government
because they allow to be used by the
united states government
in the sense
they depend wholly and solely on the
united states government for protection
forgotten that the united states they
were yes exactly they were puppets they
were puppets they forgot that the united
states didn't conquer the taliban the
taliban we are still in the country
this is not that's why i'm very
disappointed at secretly bringing in
the secretary's comments that the afghan
government and the military failed to
defend their country this is not defend
they themselves didn't conquer the
united states didn't conquer the taliban
they say so
and also the taliban believe that the
u.s will protect them forever and they
didn't rely on their regional
neighbors like iran look like what
happened in syria and
in iraq the iraqi government formerly
invited the iranian
military wing the iranian government to
help
so you see what they did they train
local militias they equip them and in
the region only iran can let their
commanders die for the peace of another
nation only iran no one else afghanistan
pakistan cannot do it
and saudi arabia cannot do that
for that for their soldiers their people
to die their commanders to die for
another country no only iran can do it
you say if they would have formally
invited iran but if they were afraid
that the united states government to
farm at them this is the whole issue
you know that happened in iran they are
in afghanistan thank you
thank you very much for that call a new
caller carombo in new york thanks for
making that call next up is david but
not yet
mike in south carolina says george it
was cowardly for you to cut me off
i'm a well-known coward mike and it was
obvious to everyone how much you
frightened me
uh
george could you and colin murray team
up with ken loach to produce a film
about last five six years
uh in the labour party says rob
what would be the point rob
what would be the point
that's the
comment i made earlier
why are people still
in
this
misnamed
grotesquely
ill-shapen apology for a
labour party how long you going to allow
them
to kill
politically kill
one after another after another of your
leading figures but still you're in
the labour party not you i don't know if
you are rob or if you're not
but what would be the point of making a
film about it
david is in croydon go ahead david
hello george it's a pleasure to speak
with you again
um i i simply wanted your opinion on
what you believe is going to happen with
the handful of british paratroopers that
have been sent to afghanistan because
clearly if the taliban turned on them
and wanted to go for them they'd be
wiped out i mean yeah
there would be rocks drift i hope uh i
hope that nothing happens to them
i hope that the taliban
realizes the good sense
in allowing foreign nationals to be
airlifted
out of the country
the banning of all commercial flights
overnight
is not a good sign only military flights
are being permitted to take off and land
and uh on the trackers there's virtually
no air activity over afghanistan this
evening
uh yeah i don't believe that joe biden's
5 000
u.s soldiers will ever arrive
if they do arrive
there'll be 5 000 targets
it will be a provocation it would be far
better to negotiate now with the taliban
for safe passage for the foreign
nationals
that are in the country that's my view
david what about you
well i agree with you i'm a former
rifleman with the royal green jackets
second battalion i didn't go to um iraq
or afghanistan we were always in west
belfast i'm a bit older than the young
guys now but
if i received an order to accompany only
600 guys out to afghanistan i wouldn't
have gone i would have disobeyed a
direct order and gone to military prison
i will uh
of course i can't uh
endorse that uh because otherwise uh
we'll get into difficulty but
i very much hope that these paratroopers
are not sent if they are sent
that no harm uh comes to them and above
all that the british
people that are there that the
paratroopers are supposed to help to get
out can get out safely
which well-known film was released in
this week in 1939 was actually
re-released
a hound of the baskervilles b
the wizard of oz
c
gone with the wind answer after the
break
radio sputnik
[Music]
you know i had uh that george galloway
back in here the other day
whoa tell you what talk about the
knowledge but the time he got out i had
a first-class degree
we are talking
24 hours a day seven days a week you are
listening
we give you the most essential out of
the endless information space
radio sputnik
telling
where's the cheese pizza robinson come
on what are the public paying you for
oh and uh got another virgin collada
while you're there there's a chap
now who's ringing the older burner phone
hello
how did you get this number delayed
no no that's impossible i can't possibly
fight in new york
why
our mummies grounded me oh yes certain
to cut off my allowance you know
yes yes i i know it comes from the
public but uh she holds the strings
oh i've uh got to go uh my my pizza will
be here uh any minute
[Music]
[Applause]
come here with that moist towelette
it's getting a bit hot for my liking
george galloway
and the mother of all talk shows join us
at the college of knowledge where there
are no tuition fees
it was of course the wonderful wizard of
oz that was re-released in 1939.
uh george you are my hero says joseph
your monologue this evening sent shivers
up my spine we knew that it was wrong to
invade afghanistan and all the other
countries spreading hatred across the
world i salute you sir i wish i was half
the man you are from jew in lancashire
thank you joe for your very kind words
tom says where the hell is the middle
east peace end boy when you need him
quite and uh tony gannon says where is
joe biden or kamla harris for that
matter they've gone to ground
and uh
al hajj
says good show i have a solution
regarding the taliban issue china has to
be convinced that a taliban testicle is
an aphrodisiac keep up the good work top
cat nice to find some
grim humor in these uh difficult uh
times should four-year-olds be allowed
to change their gender without parental
consent
yes
three percent
who are the three percent
who said yes
to that question
no 97
on youtube six percent said yes what's
wrong with you people
six percent said yes 94
said no why don't you call me and defend
your affirmative
answer on that question now just quickly
um
we did cover uh the
the case
uh brought by britney spears to remove
her father
from her guardianship and in this case
guardianship of her millions of dollars
and that case has now been resolved so
just quickly we have sarah robertson our
very own showbiz and tv editor sarah
thanks uh for coming on uh the show to
talk about this most kind of you on a
crowded uh evening just summarize what
happened on the case would you
well lawyers britney's lawyers um said
this was a major victory for her that
her father jamie spears has agreed to
step aside from the conservatorship so
they've said britney obviously launched
this um appeal
to stop her father controlling her
estate back in july which has been
played out in the courts over the last
um six weeks or so and this is this is a
victory for her which they called a
major victory that jamie spears has
agreed to
step back um as a conservator of her
estate and no longer participate in that
what he has said is that he will
allow make room for an orderly
transition for a new legal team to come
in place instead of him
yeah that's the key point isn't it uh
he's not saying that she is
a fit
uh to be in charge of her own
finances and her own life actually he's
seeing someone else rather than him is
she going to contest that sarah
at the moment it's not known if britney
is going to contest it i think for her
um her
anger at this whole situation has been
directed at
her father who she feels has been the
driving force behind this you know she
she claimed he made her perform on stage
you know when she was supposedly not
well
she's obviously made lots and lots of
claims that he was controlling her her
medical care her health how how she
lived her life he is he has contested
all of this and and things have got
without
using the pun on on her single toxic
between them um which britney obviously
sang that song and that went right over
my head sarah sorry well any britney
fans will know toxic is one of her big
hits but you know this whole family feud
has has become very toxic and even
though he stepped away it has not been
without a parting shot i i was sent the
15-page court document over over the
weekend which was what jamie had filed
or his lawyers had filed at the court in
louisiana and there was some very very
dark stuff in there he alludes to to
britney's mental health um
her physical health but says he will not
speak publicly
on that matter so he's still trying to
play the part of the the protective
father and he also chastises britney's
mother lynn
who's had a lot to say within this she
sort of come out on her daughter's side
and said yes jamie you know
has been controlling things but he took
a parting shot at lynn as well saying
that actually she's been estranged from
her daughter this is what he's claiming
for 13 years
and he has been paying lin's bills to
the cost of a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year which includes her
mansion um servants staff
all the rest of it whatever whatever
lynn needs over the last 13 years and
and what just seems to be really sad
about this is yet again it's coming down
to money with britney's family all
having their hands in the
britney pot of her 60 million dollar
fortune and and who's getting what out
of it
but it'll be interesting to see what
happens now at the moment britney just
seems to be celebrating
the fact that her father has has agreed
to relinquish this control and she's
she's making videos on instagram for her
fans where she dances and there's been a
couple where she's stripped off um you
know she's just trying to express
herself
however i just wanted to say another
thing that i i have been party to
is
brittany now is controlling her own
narrative her her spokespeople and press
people
are no longer speaking for her so
whatever comes out britney's releasing
herself to fans through her social media
she's not giving her her team any
direction in terms of what to say on her
behalf so so this is another sort of
signal and step that britney's trying to
take control back off of her life as she
sees it sounds like an accident waiting
to happen to me sarah robertson thanks
for that quick update most kind of you
to join us let's go back to the calls
michael is in australia on afghanistan
go ahead michael
yeah hi george um you got to a couple of
points afghanistan um george i think you
know obviously you're right in your
analysis of the taliban and who they are
and what they believe in i don't dispute
that for a second
um and i think you also um you know have
the
the right to
in the right correct position in saying
that basically the world should come
together to try to spoil the taliban
and um and i think there's a lot of hope
there actually um you know iran is sort
of like really the only answering iran
um pakistan's really been the only ally
if you call an ally of of the taliban
and it's quite quite remarkable that um
the taliban actually defeated america
given that even though there was only
limited support really from pakistan
they even got there was any sort of
tacit support they actually got
um you have china who are very close
allies with um
um
russia
and kazakhstan and china are all very
close allies now i'm russian china and
trying to sign the massive trade deal
with um iran
it's part of the built-in road um i'd
say this one another program i think
you'll see basically uh iran russia
china kazakhstan and pakistan work
together to stabilize the country
hopefully and i think you know it's
tragic world what's happening there in
terms of the women yes that is tragic
and you are right to point out the
hypocrisy of these liberals who go
around claiming oh the women the women
when they blow off the heads of women
all around the world every day of the
week and no one no
he doesn't write a mention
um but i think the the key and has been
proven throughout history to um
empowering women is through economic um
and in education and as as women become
needed in the workforce as they will in
afghanistan involves economic
economically um they will gain access to
education just through the pure effect
they need to be educated um to work
participate in certain fields and jobs
um so i think the best way to to develop
society in afghanistan is to develop it
economically and to cooperate with its
neighbours and hopefully all those
neighbors can come together to stabilize
afghanistan
and um also just quickly um on the
gender um choosing issue you know my
position on that i suspect not about it
before it's absolutely crazy and just on
my personal note um i have suffered um
under conservatory ships of my own
um due to what the government claims and
mental health issues
uh including once being tried and
abstentual when i was in china by the
new south wales
civil administrative tribunal and put
under medal ward of the state
but anyway that's different matter why
did you return on humanitarian i did
receive a humanitarian visa mind you um
so that you got issued by the prc in the
prc so yeah another big story we'll talk
about that another time michael thanks
for the call chris is in china in hong
kong
go ahead go ahead chris
i am george how are you this evening
fantastic band storming oh yes sir
tonight i love you
thank you look um
you've covered some of that
of course i'm opinionated usually
informed as well by the way uh a little
concern on the global warming matter
with our one x liberal mp i'm afraid i
was quite surprised at the line that he
took i must say
no uh
it's always good to muddy the waters sir
um
if you can't place them your critics you
can't have an opinion can you let's be
honest about it
yeah yeah well
our opinions are welcome chris oh
however let's get on to
the
disgraceful
conduct of the labour party
against a national treasure
a bafta award winning director
who has covered social issues in the uk
since the 60s
can
load
how
much lower
does the labour party get
and i think they'll uh they'll get lower
yet chris uh i think there's no depth uh
to how low
they can go uh ken loach is uh
is a national treasure i preferred his
earlier work myself but there's no doubt
that he's an adornment to
a british civil society even if he wants
to break up britain by
supporting scottish independence but
the idea that he should be kicked out of
the labour party a labour party in which
tony blair
uh is still welcome
that uh
the the the gang that brought us
uh the iraq and the afghan invasions uh
can still be in the labour party
while someone like ken loach is kicked
out of it is simply monstrous but my
question chris is why would you want to
be in
kier starmer's labour party
well i'm pleased to say um
[Music]
i i've been banned from the pardon twice
um
since uh 2016.
uh the first ban allegedly i i was
they didn't like me being a bit of an
ecologist and the second band was a
critique i made of um
kinnick who of course uh i was born and
bred raised in torvine kenneth was just
over the valley in reality um
the party didn't like what i had to say
about kenneth which is a view shared by
many many people
in south wales guys
i'm sure i'm sure chris that is true but
don't don't repeat that don't repeat
them now
yeah don't don't remember anything now
about kenneth go ahead
may i just add one other matter on
afghanistan yeah it relates very much to
torvine
a lot of squaddies
were recruited from south wales yeah saw
action
in afghanistan
one of my
friends from school
her daughter married
a veteran
of
afghanistan he left his hand in there
and like many others
i would want answers from blair
for what reason did that man lose his
hand very powerful very powerful
very powerful chris thank you thank you
for doing so david is in glasgow on the
same subject uh go ahead david
hi george how are you doing good thanks
good man i was wanting to ask you your
your thoughts and opinions on why is it
like afghanistan is like so um
so important to you particularly like it
seems like i've never really
understood that but i think you've got
some insight into that
it was historically purely its
geographical position uh the british
empire in india was the
uh was the jewel in the british imperial
crown
uh the russians wanted
uh to
uh get their hands on it in the in the
19th century and even uh before
uh it is cheeked by jowl with
with the former ussr with the people's
republic of china with the islamic
republic of iran
with pakistan
which has a deep conflict with india
over kashmir
so it was strategically extremely
important but in recent times
it has been discovered to be
the site of
undreamt of treasures of real earth
minerals and the kind of things that we
need for our phones and for uh all kinds
of
new scientifically lithium
electric cars all of that
is to be found in abundance in
afghanistan which adds to
its geostrategic importance uh
geographically speaking last what do you
david
you know thanks that's the interesting
like insight i would just i've always
been about uh
why there's such a
i so many enjoy
so many empires it's the graveyard of
empires dave thanks for the call dan is
in liverpool go ahead dan
hello felix you know what you just stole
you just stole my in fact uh
introduction it is the graveyard of
vampires sorry man sorry and everything
you just said is it's very accurate
actually i just watched in fact i just
streamed because my stream a great
documentary called um if i can check
again to make sure i don't um get this
wrong it was called bitterly by adam
curtis yeah very very powerful film yeah
everybody watch it it's two hours long
just you know get your popcorn or
whatever but i i would highly suggest it
i just want your thoughts on
is this is this a wake-up call sir not
the west in terms of
this so-called inverted commerce
intelligence that we clearly failed us
for 70 years i mean since 1955. do you
think this is a wake-up call for the
populations of the west well i hope so
it's further proof dan that uh we're run
by not by james bonds but by austin
powers
our military brass our austin powers our
intelligence services our austin powers
the intelligence services that told joe
biden
that the afghan national army was as
strong as any army in the world and
could withstand the taliban for between
90 days minimum and 12 months
uh are austin powers that's the kind of
level of intelligence briefing you're
going to get from austin powers
okay can i can i i mean this is slightly
personal but i mean don't take this
offense with me i'm not i'm not trying
to be a fancy when he was in congress
right and these
i would say
okay i need to find a better way instead
of the word i want to use and
incredulous people i would say is that
the way they want it is and we're
questioning you in front of congress
like
what was your feeling with these people
who
think they're smart in terms of their
foreign policy ideas and and what you
went through well
it's a long story uh uh we should uh
talk about it when we've got more time
but uh for me it was a chance to
get up close and personal with power
and uh there is uh
there is uh a special reward in heaven
for those that speak the truth in the
court of the sultan and i was in the
court of the sultan in the presence of
of american
senators thanks uh very much dan for
that call i must get through some social
media tony says who on earth was
briefing the white house and downing
street shocking intelligence failure in
both countries
so much so tony that the british foreign
secretary was sitting on a beach
somewhere overseas
yeah i'm not joking he's had to come
back from his holiday
to supervise the total collapse of the
imperial project in afghanistan peter's
in middlesborough on elvis how could i
resist peter
uh-huh
i just want to know this i'll change the
subject they're going on about prince
andrew with a 17 year old last the
american doesn't make the big deal of it
i want to know now why no one has ever
mentioned elvis presley moving priscilla
in a 13-year-old with the parents
consent and then when she became legally
the age to marry her so he can't
talk about him
in court he married her
yeah well what did he do he would say
that this relationship was never
consummated until she was 16.
i know but we all know that's bollocks
well i don't know i wasn't there i i'm
surprised you well i'm surprised you
were why would you want to move a 15
year old into his mansion come and be
truthful well
she wasn't 13 when she moved into his
mansion but you're right she was 13.
hold on she was 13 when he started
dating her uh with her parents uh
consent and it was very very odd indeed
uh
that priscilla
who's very lovely it seems uh what 13
no no
that she's very lovely uh it's a
surprise that her parents let her uh
consort with elvis maybe it was the
maybe it was the money pete
well it was like michael jackson if he
lives in the caravan you know down your
door and said can your uh 12 year old
son sleep with me i'm 50. you get locked
up if elvis popping your daughter said
can i let your 13 you all move my
mansion you smack my mouth but no one
ever mentions it because
it's a good it's a it's a perfectly i
don't know what he got up to definitely
a good point
didn't jerry lee lewis marry somebody at
yeah well i don't know jerry lylos
who's jerry lee lewis words i've never
thought here thanks peter neil is in
canada let's hear from him go ahead neil
hi george hi
i'd like
i'd like to make a couple of comments
one on
afghanistan one on
climate change with regards to
all the stories we're hearing out of
california yeah um
my my nephew
as a canadian armed forces corporal went
to afghanistan
and he did two tours of dewey
and he came back
terribly messed up mentally because he
had got he had a guy die in his arms etc
and that's pretty tough for an 18 year
old sure anyway
the two comments he made when he got
home that i think might be of interest
are
canada here where there is p or there is
peacekeepers the u.s are there to fight
a war so why are we take why are we the
canadians taking our orders from the
americans
good question and the other thing he
said and he said there are lots of young
canadians dying so the canadian officers
can make big names for themselves yeah
thank you you shouldn't underestimate
the military inertia the careers that
are made uh amongst the top brass uh
neil you're gonna have to call me on
climate change next week because
we're out of time and there's a legend
on the line it's norma in bristol norma
welcome
hello george um
just quickly
this is about the taliban
um
how to negotiate change with sharia law
which is what the taliban believe well
they're entitled to uh have their own
law we've got our own uh law
well
i'm not sure that the occupants of the
electric chair in the united states
would think it other than cruel
every country has the right to its own
legal system afghanistan is a
more or less 100 percent muslim country
it's entitled to
have muslim law isn't it
no but i don't think two wrongs make a
right it's not right for somebody who
steals to have their hand taken off well
i don't think it's right but then i'm
not an afghan
what right have you got uh in bristol to
decide what the penal code is in
afghanistan
because i'm a human being
malala
she is the one who was terrorized by the
taliban
was shot in the head yeah yeah
and she's tweeted how worried she is
i mean i would have the right to be
worried she's got every right to be
worried so i'm worried at the end of the
day you can't go around the world
reordering it according to our
view of things norma i'm surprised that
you
don't seem to have grasped that point
well i suppose i have in a way because i
don't think it's right if you steal
something you have your blooming hunting
but you're not going to send your son
or his son
to go and die in afghanistan
to uphold your uh your view of of uh
crime and punishment these are matters
that you can only leave
to the people in the country norma
but you need to negotiate a better deal
with the taliban
but you can't that's what you you said
yeah and i i strongly agree with that
but for example
uh in america you get the gas chamber
and you get injected with lethal
substances you get electrocuted in the
electric chair but these are things or
you can own
50 automatic weapons but these are not
things the american people would allow
english people
still less afghan people to the side are
they
no but i mean they don't put you in the
electorate chair if you've stolen
something do they
you know and have your hunting off i
think yeah
they put people in the electric chair
they haven't done anything at all
as long as they're the right as long as
they're the right color and the right
class do you not see where all this
uh orientalism ends up uh norma when you
take it upon yourself to decide how
women
should dress in someone else's country
whether they're allowed to have
lipstick
whether they are going to have their
hand chopped off if they're a thief
that is the road to the invasion and
occupation of other people's countries
which quite apart from being a much
bigger crime
a much bigger crime
doesn't work
if we've learned anything from today's
events surely to god it is that invading
and occupying other people's countries
doesn't work
engenders
even more hatred and problems around the
world don't forget to get the podcast it
was up 150 last week i want to see the
same next week
thanks for watching
[Music]
you